challenge the whole idea of the Sacred
nature of the process of selecting
somebody to lead the Catholic church
until death so I think it was a shock
when he decided to voluntary voluntarily
abdicate and that day when he did fly
off into the distance I don't think
anyone quite knew how the rudder would
be reformed but Francis has been that
Rudder and brought to the papacy an end
of much of the Splendor that then
surrounded it and turned it into a much
more servant papacy than perhaps
Benedict XVI had followed
and Alice give us an idea of what
normally happens when a pope dies and
how different will this be given that
Pope Benedict had stepped aside and was
no longer holding that position at the
time of his death
well it's quite difficult because there
is no modern precedent
I would imagine that Pope Francis will
want to give an elegant and proper
respect for funeral for a previous Pope
but in a sense it won't come with all
the same Splendor which starts
the process that the REM Catholic Church
follows called the saido vacante or the
empty seat which is when all the
Cardinals of the world come to form a
conclave and select a successor so it
will not have all of that splendor but
you know the Vatican really knows how to
put on Splendor if that is what the pope
decides is appropriate for Benedict XVI
and I dare say there will be some there
are elements of the Grandeur of a papacy
that has been part of European history
going back for
really to the start of the church itself
and much of that will be brought into
effect and I'm sure there will be a
gathering in Rome and there will be an
appropriate funeral but it will probably
be not done until after the New Year is
settled and in accordance with whatever
the pope and The Business of the church
defines
and briefly if you can Alistair if you
were asked to to reflect on his time as
Pope how would you perhaps sum up Pope
Benedict XVI Legacy
following on from John Paul II who
became a saint
it was always going to be a difficult
act to follow and I think that the Roman
Catholic church had to face an enormous
amount of untidy Linen in its cupboard
and perhaps Benedict XVI showed his
ultimate nobility by stepping back from
a role that he felt he couldn't properly
fulfill and for that humility and
servanthood I think people remember him
very well
thanks very much indeed so the breaking
news this hour the pope Emeritus
Benedict XVI has died aged 95.
it's 10 o'clock you're watching Sky News
a reminder of our breaking news this
morning the Vatican has announced that
former Pope Benedict XVI has died age
95.
the Vatican news service routes The
Following on Twitter with sorrow I
inform you that the pope Emeritus
Benedict XVI passed away today at 9 34
in the motto ecclesii Monastery in the
Vatican further information will be
provided as soon as possible our Europe
correspondent Siobhan Robbins looks back
at his life
he was known as the intellectual Pope
the son of a policeman a child who lived
through Nazi rule in 2005 Cardinal
Joseph ratzinger became Benedict XVI the
first German to be elected Pope in a
thousand years
an uncompromising theological
conservative Cardinals chose him as a
safe Pair of Hands
Benedict Was a shy person he loved books
he loved his desk writing reflecting
bringing in beautiful German and then
also in other languages his thought but
a lonely person
he was even telling people my true
friends are the books
nicknamed God's rottweiler for his
uncompromising conservative views as a
cardinal at times his eight-year papacy
was marked by missteps the
rehabilitation of a holocaust denier
angering Jews a clumsy speech
antagonizing Muslims
but many respected his deep faith
his strength was clearly how to express
the Christian faith in a way
understandable to Modern human beings
that's
his message that's what he leaves us
among Catholics Benedict Was widely
popular in 2010 he made the first ever
papal State visit to the UK welcomed by
a crowd of adoring pilgrims
before meeting Queen Elizabeth
politicians and giving dozens of sermons
but his visit was controversial for
critics who claimed he was not doing
enough to tackle sex abuse in the church
a topic which would haunt him into his
retirement
the number one challenge for Pope
Benedict Was the abuse crisis which was
just gaining it in in speed and
spreading all over the world during his
pontificate and he did take several
steps to begin to respond to that but
his critics say that he he didn't do
enough in the time that he was the pope
in 2013 tired by a Vatican League
Scandal and dogged by ill health
benedict made history again
this time becoming the first pope in 600
years to resign
in his final address to the faithful
he acknowledged the weight of the office
and the church's problems
it was a journey with joy and light but
there have also been difficult moments
than in an extraordinary chapter for the
Catholic church he said goodbye to the
Cardinals before retiring to a monastery
in Vatican City
that was a remarkable step he made and
there hadn't been a pope since the
Middle Ages though who stepped down so
he as a fairly conservative person was
also opening a door
to a world of today where people need
not to stay in office until they die
after retirement Benedict chose to keep
wearing white give interviews and not
revert his old name decisions critics
claimed threatened the unity in the
church
but the two popes personal relationship
was strong France is referring to his
predecessor as a grandfather figure and
asking people to pray for his friend as
his health deteriorated
he's very sick he told worshipers in
December asking the Lord to comfort him
to the very end
today Benedict is remembered again as
millions of Catholics around the world
pray for the man who led their church
for almost a decade
Sky News
[Applause]
foreign
just announced in the last hour by the
Vatican they announced they used by
tweet saying that would sorrow I inform
you that the pope Emeritus Benedict XVI
passed away today at 9 34 in the Mata
Ecclesia Monastery in the Vatican and
they've promised to provide further
information as soon as it is possible
let's see if we can get some more now
from Rob Harris he joins us from The
Newsroom and Rob the the former Pope had
of course been very ill hadn't he yeah
concerns have been raised about is
increasingly frail status particularly
in recent days with Pope Francis asking
people to pray for Benedict and the
sense had been from the Vatican that the
situation had been worse and despite the
fact they were saying his condition had
been stable at some points during the
week and the situation now with the
announcement with the Vatican saying
that Pope Emeritus Benedict died at 9 34
local time this morning and they do say
that as of Monday morning the body of
the Pope Emeritus will be in Saint
Peter's Basilica so as they say the
faithful can Bid Farewell now as a
former head of state there would usually
be a funeral with great official
delegations from around the world
leaders of other countries to honor the
pope this is a very different situation
for the Vatican to be dealing with one
they haven't encountered for 600 years
of papal resignation in 2013 with
Benedict then stepping aside due to his
ill health so funeral preparations will
have been underway given his
increasingly frail status but obviously
such a sense of occasion would be
expected as we hear the pageantry and
pomp at the Vatican is something that
they are renowned for and the fact is
now the um the situation is they are
preparing for this and this had been a
shock announcement in 2013 with Pope
Benedict announcing he would stand aside
a situation they weren't prepared for
but perhaps a reflection that it was
time to pass on to new leadership and
for Benedict himself someone who had
dedicated his recent life to prayer and
medication and meditation and he had
been living in the monastery in Vatican
City where Pope Francis had visited him
in recent days and where he had urged
for the Catholic world and the wider
world to be praying for the health of
Pope Benedict
okay Rob Harris they're bringing us
Upstate from The Newsroom thank you rob
for now let's bring in Ruth Gledhill
she's the assistant editor at the weekly
Catholic journal the tablet uh thanks so
much for joining us here on Sky News as
we were hearing from our correspondent
Rob we are somewhat in Uncharted
Territory here uh after all Pope
Benedict was the first pope in
centuries really to to resign this
effect that was effectively two two
popes I mean what happens next this is
rather Uncharted isn't it yes so the
first in 600 years and um though he was
Pope Emeritus and that was Pope Francis
as well and I think we can say that it
was a success
um people were worried that it would be
a kind of rival this
um two papers she's going at the same
time but um although there were some
attempts by people
maybe on the conservative side to keep
Pope Benedict up there as the main Pope
you know
um it did really work that Benedict
resisted any attempts to
um make him a figurehead of a different
style of paper stew than Hearts just
subsequently embraced and they worked
really well together and he was like a
spiritual father or grandfather
um to Pope Francis
um during his time in the monastery in
the Vatican so what happens next well
there isn't a protocol that there
obviously is a very clear protocol for
when there's a pope in office dies but
there isn't a protocol for when they
retired Pope dies so there are kind of
starting well not quite from scratch
because everything will everything there
will be lots of things there that they
can use that as would normally happen
but obviously we won't be building up to
a concrete now I suspect that um longer
term uh you know after the funeral ass
and um our potential settle down a bit
you might well see Pope Francis take the
same route and retire himself and then
then we might have a conclave so we
could have a conclave maybe 18 months or
two years something like that depending
on how Pope francis's own health is uh
he he is um
has a very dodgy knee which I think
gives him a bit of discomfort but apart
from that she's still vigorous and I'm
traveling and full of
ambition and ideas for the church you
know he's got his agenda reform in the
church and promoting women to a more
prominent role in in the structures of
the church he's got lots of things he
still wants to do so I don't think it
will be imminent his retirement but I
think Pope Benedict did set um a
precedent yes and and that will now be
um probably the way things go in the
future yeah that's interesting that that
the pulp Emeritus Benedict really had
set that precedent there
um it's also interesting you mentioned
Ruth the the two popes had a
relationship they worked very well
together because they did come from from
quite distinct ends of of the spectrum
really politically and and and and
culturally Francis is known to be to be
quite liberal whereas uh Benedict really
was very very conservative wasn't he yes
so um Francis was a Latin Pope actually
in terms of Doctrine he's not really a
liberal if you look at what you know
what he's changed well he hasn't changed
things
um really he's you know he doesn't
intend to ordain women police for
example
um he has maintained the conservative
position that um Catholic of of Catholic
Doctrine but he has a different feel to
his papacy
um but probably because of his Latin
background because of his
um Jesuit background and it's a papacy
where he's he's it's a different style
of paper too there's no question about
that and it's been quite exciting and
interesting
um to see the church develop and change
under that and we have the synodal
process underway for example
um we will definitely want to see that
out I would have thought before he took
any steps towards retirement himself but
um this normal process he's trying to
empower the laity in the church and
bring the voice of the late he took a
four whereas with with Benedict it was
much more traditional
um a kind of a top-down church as as one
would expect and as was the norm really
um and uh he came with this reputation
before for this time as prefect of the
congregation for the doctrine of the
face of being um
um quite strict on Doctrine but that
wasn't the whole story because when
um people when he came to Britain we saw
the side of Pope Benedict that everyone
um loved and came to love and
um and they came to understand him much
more and the complexity of his character
and his um
deep deep spirituality and his deep
faith and his lovely um his lovely
sensitive nature and I think that you
know there was lots and lots to really
admire about Benedict and about of his
paper about his papacy and the humility
he showed at stepping down when he felt
he no longer was able to continue
okay uh Ruth Gledhill uh great to have
you with us on Sky use thank you so much
for providing us that great context Into
The Life and Legacy really of the former
Pope Benedict XVI who died this Saturday
morning at the age of 95. thank you
let's head across now to Brussels where
we can join our Europe correspondents
Adam Parsons uh Adam as we were saying
to Rob we we knew uh the Pope Benedict
was very very unwell but certainly this
news will be received as a shock to many
across Europe
particularly given the The Uncommon
situation of having two popes around at
the same time
yeah but it is unprecedented uh news for
600 years we haven't had the situation
of of two popes uh I mean let's be
honest a 95 year old frail man comes the
end of his life is not a surprise
particularly when Pope Francis had made
it very clear that he wanted the world
to remember uh the pope Emeritus in
their prayers we could see that he was
coming to the end uh of his life I think
extraordinary as well though that this
should happen at this time at this holy
period and it will create questions
about how this is managed about the
solemnity that is provided and about
this this difference this question about
what happens next now clearly as it
would have been with the death of a
British monarch the Vatican will have
prepared for this moment but there's no
precedent there's no protocol about what
to do with the funeral arrangements for
a pope America process when you have a
successor still there in the in the
papacy so we know that Benedict will be
in some Peter's Basilica line four what
is described as greetings from Monday
then I suspect they may well want to
wait until the end uh of the Holy period
in January before conducting the funeral
but that is still to be announced
suggestion is that of course that this
funeral will not have quite the standing
that it would do when a pope were to die
in office but it would be something like
an area between the death of the bishop
of Roman and The Death of a head of
state but again these arrangements are
are still being considered as the world
takes takes in the uh the after effects
the ripples of the death of of this man
he was the bridge of course after John
Paul II such a famous and and renowned
and beloved a very different character
much more of an academic than he had
been a Hands-On pastoral priest and
somebody who whose teachings do seem to
have been a considerable contrast to
Pope Francis a very interesting question
about whether or not this could be a a
prompt for Pope Francis himself to
consider standing down from the role I
think it is worth saying that when
Benedict decided to retire he made his
announcement in Latin in front of a
group of journalists and at that time
there was only one journalist in that
room who spoke Latin it was a fairly
extraordinary moment because she was the
only journalist there who realized what
had happened and many of the Cardinals
who were listening in didn't realize
what had happened because they were not
fluent in in Latin either I think that
was in a sense in essence that was what
Pope Benedict XVI stood for a nod
towards tradition towards that link with
the old traditions of the church and of
course that was something that also
dogged him that his his defense of uh of
of clerics who had clearly committed
sexual abuse and I think over the course
of his uh eight year reign as Pope it
became apparent to him that that he had
uh tried in a sense to downplay damage
that over those eight years became more
and more apparent to him and there are
many stories of of him five times
meeting survivors of sexual abuse and
then stories of him breaking down into
tears as he read uh their accounts I
think that for him was a was a journey
in a sense a Journey of Faith uh for the
pope and uh in subsequent interviews
after he had stood down for the job he
talked of of the difficulty that he'd
faced leading the church and of making
those tough decisions he was a complex
truly complex character Born Into the
the political turmoil of Germany in the
20s
forced to become a member of the Hitler
Youth despite being the son of a father
who who absolutely adamantly uh hated uh
the Nazis and from a family who uh well
his his father was was in the police
force but a number of his family members
were in the priesthood and that was
something that he always wanted to do
from his very earliest years and then
but coming into that job the oldest pope
who had been uh appointed the first for
600 years to retire so in a sense I I
think we may look back and say that that
Benedict Was A memorable Pope for the
things that happened around him for his
age for the way he retired for the way
that he did uh have to deal with that
extraordinarily uncomfortable and
horrific series of sexual abuse scandals
and allowing them in a way to come into
the open and acting as a bridge to Pope
Francis a significant Global figure and
for Catholic collection for followers of
the Catholic Church all around the world
I think this will be a day of of
reflection and sorry
okay Adam Parson there our Europe
correspondents thank you very much
indeed well let's get more on The Life
and Legacy of the former Pope Benedict
the 16th we can speak now with the
historian Anthony Selden and it's good
to have you with us here on Sky News
just talk to us about about the Legacy
that Pope Benedict leaves behind I mean
it was a it was a an eight-year paper
seed it could be considered quite quite
quite a short term one before he took
that that rather significant decision to
to stand down and resign
quite a a relatively short paper C uh
obviously an immensely sad uh day uh and
event for Catholics and for others
worldwide but uh unlikely to be
remembered as one of the significant or
more historic of the papacy is not least
for the brevity likely to be remembered
exactly for creating that
600-year precedent of atstanding down uh
so not carrying on all the way to death
and and
um and also who just had remembered also
for
um the
allegations of child abuse uh and abuse
in general
um that came to light during the papacy
so uh clearly many strong personal uh
virtues uh did he take the church in a
new to direction will he be remembered
for many new initiatives uh probably not
but a man as you've been hearing a a
very great spirituality and depth and uh
sincerity so uh the most likely Legacy
will be standing down with exactly the
questions there will
um that the current Pope Francis follow
that route I'm I'm doubtful but who
knows
but in a way it could be it could be
rather transformative further down the
lines by setting this precedent really I
mean he could end up being one of the
more transformative popes in the the
Catholic church at Church's history
um
yes
um uh but to be uh to make a mark uh as
hope uh you need longevity uh you need
to have
um a a receptive uh Church ready to uh
to to take the church in a New Direction
you need to have a pope
um very certain of the direction which
they're going to be taking at the church
um and uh Pope Francis the current pope
might well do that
um and uh that that could be exactly
what the church needs so there will be
uh difficult uh but in general uh what's
significant about
uh one of the most significant factors
about the very sad news is that
um first time in 17 years the pope uh
has died is is that that's such a major
event in in world history and the
speculation about who will be the
successor none of that uh is present now
so a lot of the reasons why this has
been such a a huge event in uh world
media uh and World politics in the past
is absent now because we know uh who is
going to take over and it may be that uh
um without uh the his predecessor living
uh there
um uh indeed it is very mixed uh this
will liberate uh Pope Francis
um in in a not this wholly dissimilar
way that King Charles uh might be
liberated now
um without his mother uh at the late
Queen uh there and we might see a rather
different uh and a more or Resolute Pope
Francis steering the church in the
direction that he thinks is right
that is an interesting point you raise
because certainly we did go from the
very traditional uh Pope Benedict to
Pope Francis who uh what we heard
perhaps not a liberal but widely viewed
as a on on a different end of the
spectrum from uh Pope Benedict and there
was that tension there wasn't there of
having two ports around at the same time
particularly since uh Benedict's
became Pope Emeritus and continued
wearing white which is rather
significant isn't it
were very significant and some of uh
that those nuances were brought out in
the rather Beautiful film that some uh
might have seen uh called the two popes
uh a couple of years or three years or
so ago and extraordinary
um extraordinary but it's very hard
psychologically for any leader uh if
they feel their predecessor is breathing
down their neck and particularly
um we've just been hearing from your
previous political predecessors on the
program about how uh Francis may not be
uh that great reformer
um uh and a very much more liberal
figure
um that some people think he is but we
may see more of that contemporary uh
liberality uh in uh Pope Francis coming
out now that
um subconsciously psychologically he is
freed of his uh successor uh are living
almost literally breathing down his neck
who knows uh but that could be one of
the more interesting aspects uh of
what's of the sad news that's just
happened yeah absolutely just quickly I
mean how United is the the Catholic
church right now because
there have been tensions haven't there
between the more traditional wings and
the more uh more liberal if you like
wings of the church
do you think that this changes anything
or
others will be better placed to to give
a an informed view on that my own view
is that every single
um aspect of of the the Christian church
has indeed other face are united as they
face our contemporary issues of of uh of
women uh in the clergy and issues around
gay and and gender identity uh and
contemporary morals it's a very
difficult time for any uh religious
Authority that
um uh that that is grounded on on deep
reverence and respect for Doctrine uh to
adapt and to know how far uh to adapt uh
and how far is right and how far that
means losing your core base uh so yes at
Riven and it will require enormous
sensitivity and Imagination
um and the potential for Pope Francis to
be an even better uh own and more
impactful uh hope if he gets it right
even then Pope John Paul II Benedict's
predecessor okay Anthony Selden the
historian they're joining us live on Sky
News thank you very much indeed for
sharing your thoughts though
Let's uh speak now to Deborah Castellano
lubov she's correspondents at the
Vatican news and joins us now
thank you so much for being with us here
on
uh Sky News this is this is difficult
news uh for people not just in the
Vatican but beyond to absorb this
morning isn't it
yes it certainly is we noticed with the
downturn in the recent days that
something had been different because in
these years there had been a lot of
um false alarms obviously the pope
Emeritus is is 95 and he's been a frail
and very frail for a while now but most
recently uh the news coming from the
Vatican about uh the former Pope's uh
deteriorating Health due to Advanced
stage even despite the fact that it had
been stable um the past two days um even
though Pope Francis had made public
appeals earlier in the week at his
General audience to pray for his uh
predecessor so it's it's very um sad
news and many people are shocked even
though we've all been preparing for this
and we certainly have been alarmed this
week hearing about the retired popes
condition
okay and Deborah you you met the pope
Emeritus didn't you yes yes yes talk to
us about your Recollections of him
I think that what many see in them in
the media doesn't properly capture
um the the pope Emeritus because when
you're one on one with him he's actually
very
um kind and gentle and
um many
ordinary Catholics have described a
certain sense of Holiness and he was
very down to earth like I
um I know that when he had uh met with
myself and even my husband before we got
married quickly for a quick blessing it
was it was a private audience and
um he he asked us normal questions that
anyone would ask you and he held my hand
and
um was very warm and affectionate so
um that encounter in particular
um was very
[Music]
um
special for me and it definitely
contrasted with what we normally see as
the cold Rottweiler who's us very rigid
or
um that most narratives definitely
present within within the media yes
it's amazing to hear that perspective I
the current Pope Francis as well yes
there's a lot of talk about how the the
pope Emeritus and Pope Francis had quite
a warm and cordial relationship it was
really uh summed up in that that
Charming film with the two ports I mean
giving you've met both I mean does that
sort of tally with
with your experience of them
certainly I think the reality
demonstrates a a nice cordial
relationship between
Pope Francis the reigning Pope and no
longer Pope the former retired Pope uh
Benedict the 16th and even in their own
words Whenever there have been
um encounters for anniversaries of
ordinations or sometimes around the
consistory for the creation of new
Cardinals we see that there have been
only words of esteem and gratitude by
Benedict to Pope Francis for having him
stay in in the Vatican Gardens and
really welcoming him and that they
really appreciate how the other in their
own way is sustaining the church in the
case of Benedict XVI that has been in
silent prayer uh prayer for the church
and uh Pope Francis himself in these
days has certainly been appealing to the
whole world to pray for his uh
predecessor and uh praising his witness
of love for the church they may not see
eye to eye they may have different
approaches but I think there's
definitely a mutual respect among them
and even if there's been moments where
Benedict has spoken publicly and maybe
he's had points of view that were in uh
in line with those of Pope Francis in
these years for the most part he has not
interfered during this pontificate he
has just been praying and having some
meetings at his residence in the
monastery the Monterey Blasio Monastery
in the Vatican Gardens and encouraging
Pope Francis to do what
um what he's been doing to lead the
Church of today
it was a a terribly unusual situation
that wasn't it I mean the the pope
Emeritus became the first pope to resign
in in in 600 years and and while Pope
Francis
assumed the papacy his predecessor was
still there in the background I mean
this must have been very very
challenging though
certainly uh everyone could understand
how uh that could be a very challenging
situation even
but at the same time despite this um
very Innovative and surprising decision
of Benedict XVI to resign after eight
years of leading the Catholic Church due
to uh lack of strength
and um
we see that despite that they have found
their own they found their own Rhythm if
you will in the sense that um there
wasn't this interference and despite
some who um I would say the biggest
issue had been perhaps those who still
look to Benedict as a pope one Benedict
himself the 16th had just made it clear
he was no longer Pope so some who feel
so against change within the the
Catholic church that they're holding
trying to hold on to the past but
Benedict XVI was very clear when he took
that radical decision to step down
freely and publicly that he was no
longer Pope well you say he he was very
clear but but he he assumed the the name
Pope Emeritus he continued to wear white
he many on the more conservative
spectrum of the uh of the Catholic
Church continued to to look up to him
really as some are more aligned with
their values do you think
um Pope Benedict's death
will change a certain Dynamic within the
Catholic Church moving forward
will the church become more united do
you think
well I would hope so you know we'll have
to see
um what what happens but yeah certainly
there has been
um these are the very questions that
many have been asking themselves
um like these are the elements that had
caused uh confusion
um to some because it left uh there had
been a a cardinal
um who had also criticized the fact of
wearing choosing to wear white
especially
um because he felt that these elements
created confusion that otherwise may not
have been
um that would have other has been clear
that
um but it's if you look at the Catholic
church if you look at archdiocese around
the world especially now the fact that
people are living longer in general
there's all there's often Bishop
emeritus's Cardinal or you know it's a
common
um phenomenon that there's still someone
living kind of in the background so I
don't think it should be taken with the
proper uh context that um he was all
very elderly his health no longer
permitted him to leave the church he
didn't want to stop the church and from
being able to proceed in the way that it
needed to he wouldn't have been able to
continue traveling transatlantically
like he had done in the past for
important events and it is that was the
substance behind behind the resignation
because no one stays in a position that
they
that's that challenging
um for that long if uh if you were
looking to get out of it from the
beginning so he inherited a lot of
problems you know and there were a lot
of scandals
um during that pontificate but if he was
looking to get out of it he wouldn't
have waited until the eighth year there
was um a health there were health
reasons why he felt that he no longer
could could lead things and he's been
um very encouraging to to Pope Francis
but obviously Pope Francis has been
Mount uh
managing a very interesting
unprecedented dynamic in a very graceful
way yes talk to us about his legacy
because because this is such an unusual
situation the uh the first papal
resignation in 600 years his papacy
risks being defined by that but but what
would you point to as being
um Pope Benedict xvi's real Legacy
because because there have been
scandals uh but this perhaps he could be
remembered for this this more
transformative step that he took which
which commentators have speculated uh
the current Pope Francis could follow as
well so how would you look back on his
legacy what's his defining moment
yes well certainly the resignation will
be the main thing that people as a whole
remember but depending on who you speak
to if you speak to someone just you know
kind of following externally they'll
point to that and they'll probably think
of how conservative he was and how he
didn't want to open up to you know the
modern the modern world but uh we we do
need to keep into account that
um objectively he was sort of seen as
this like Professor uh scholarly
brilliant uh intellect
um that he uh also like many think of
various things that uh his predecessor
uh Pope uh Saint John Paul II
accomplished uh Cardinal rotzinger was
behind a lot of of those initiatives and
even if there were all the scandals with
um clerical sexual abuse it was
um both Benedict XVI who did uh deplore
filth within the church in a very public
speech and took concrete steps against
clerical sexual abuse including when he
was head of the vatican's doc
congregation to the doctrine of the
faith he changed the laws about the
statute of limitations and he made um
pedophilia
immediately a
delictum graviorum which is like of the
greatest seriousness within the church
as a crime so that you would be
immediately
excommunicated and changed other laws
relating to
um minors and any sort of uh
pornographic images of of minors
Etc so even Pope Francis himself has
said that what I am doing is in
continuity with that which my
predecessor started because Benedict had
taken concrete measures in Bennett and
Francis has been building a lot on those
even if there's still many elements that
many feel especially victims of of abuse
feel that still should be done but
Benedict Was strongly behind
um that that movement he was very strict
doctrinally and even if there amendments
understandings between other faiths you
had worked to build Bridges
he was a prolific author he had written
a beautiful Jesus of Nazareth series of
wrote three encyclicals he went to he
traveled at the most for an advanced a
pope of an advanced age more than any
other Pope you know he was elected he
was the pope who was elected
at the oldest age you know in history
and he always traveled until he couldn't
and he supported his uh his successor
you know because he could have you know
kind of tried to control things
behind the scenes and instead he um he
really kind of let Pope Francis do what
he was he feels is necessary and every
so often he's released interviews or
maybe said that I have a different
perspective on things but for the most
part they coexisted nicely almost like a
little family within the Vatican within
the Vatican Gardens
so I think that he leaves a very rich
Legacy into ordinary Catholics to be
seen as someone of of Holiness and uh
someone who
has of gentleness and just a certain
Brilliance and others have spoken that
he could even possibly be a doctor of of
the church at some point like obviously
there's uh nothing to that now but his
uh Brilliance is something that will
never be forgotten my mind like like
that but obviously the the scandals have
clouded
um a lot of the good that he has done
but uh will be a lot of sadness in in
realm and by Catholics for the losing of
the Pope and artists absolutely
um well Deborah Castellano uh luboff
correspondent at the Vatican news thank
you so much for for sharing your
Recollections your personal
Recollections uh of Pope Benedict XVI
and urinalysis there we do appreciate it
well we have got reaction coming in
though from Cardinal Vincent Nichols the
heads of the Catholic church in England
and Wales he has said that I am deeply
saddened to learn of the death of Pope
Benedict he will be remembered as one of
the great theologians of the 20th
century I remember with particular
affection the remarkable people visit to
these lands in 2010
we saw his courtesy his gentleness his
perceptiveness of his mind and openness
of his welcome to everybody he met he
was through and through a gentleman a
scholar a pastor a man of God close to
the Lord and always his humble servants
Pope Benedict is very much in my heart
and in my prayers I give thanks to God
for his ministry and Leadership making
less rest rather in peace and rise in
glory that's from the uh from
Cardinal Vincent Nichols heads of the
Catholic church in England and Wales the
Prime Minister has also
tweeted uh from his accounts uh saying
that I am saddened to learn of the death
of Pope Emeritus Benedict XVI
he was a great Theologian whose UK visit
in 2010 was an historic moment for both
Catholics and non-catholics throughout
our country my thoughts are with
Catholic people in the UK and around the
world today so that's the Prime Minister
Rishi sunac
sharing his thoughts and tributes on the
death of Pope emeritus
Benedicts the 16th if he died earlier
this morning let's uh speak now with
Christopher Lam is Rome correspondence
for the tablet that's a weekly Catholic
journal and we are now starting to see a
lot more of these tributes coming in
Pope Benedict's papacy was rather short
compared to others but but he has
clearly left a mark hasn't he
absolutely I think for people in Britain
the mark really is is was left through
his visit in 2010 which if you remember
was kind of preceded with a lot of
negative publicity it was
you know at one point thought that it
would kind of be a almost a disaster but
it was a huge success in the end and I
think many people still remember that
visit and I would describe that visit as
one of if not the highlight of his
pontificate
um which was at times trouble there were
scandals there were difficulties
um he had to take steps to tackle the
clerical sexual sexual abuse scandals
which he sought to uh to to deal with
however as we know from this uh terrible
scourge of abuse that is that has been
playing the church there were still
things that he he could have done or he
could have gone further with
um I do think though that the real
Legacy of Benedict will be that
courageous and humble decision to resign
the papacy without that resignation we
would not have had the election of Pope
Francis it's a decision that has changed
the church
forever
not least because it led to the election
of Francis but also because it has set a
precedent for other people resignations
and is therefore form the office of the
papacy
I think for the foreseeable future you
know in the past it was seen that the
pope was like Monica would stay until
until death but Benedict threw a really
Monumental and historic decision has
changed that
it really was seen as a very
conservative a very traditional
influence he was elected really
um after Jean-Paul II for because people
wanted to seek continuity a safe Pair of
Hands really was how uh some pooted and
in the end he's turned out to be perhaps
one of the most transformative with that
decision
to stand down
I think that's right that that is the
the irony of Benedict
um now throughout his life there was a
clearly a tension within him between
someone who was a reformer and someone
who was more trying to maintain the
status quo or more conservative as a
young Theologian he
uh very reform-minded uh he attended the
second Vatican Council the Gathering of
Catholic bishops from 1962 to 1965 which
sought to shape the church for the
Contemporary era
um it was a hugely influential moment
for the Catholic church and his Council
which is still being implemented uh
today and Benedict played a very
important role in that Council as a
theological advisor as a a young
Theologian but later on he shifted his
position he became concerned by the pace
of reforms he was concerned by what I
think he saw as some politicization of
the church so radicalization in some
parts and he therefore moved his moved
positions in a certain extent and when
he was chosen as the prefect of the
Congress creation of the doctrine of the
faith in 1981 by John Paul II he
set about trying to draw out some
clearer red lines around what is
acceptable and what is not in terms of
Catholic Doctrine and teaching and he
gained a reputation as something of an
enforcer at the same time those who know
him and those who have
spent time with him always remark at
them as a very kind gentle person not a
confrontational man at all naturally a
theologian who was happier studying and
writing and teaching rather than
uh governing the church and I think that
was one of the difficulties for
spontificate is that whilst he was a
brilliant teacher the elements of the
papal office which involved governing
appointing people uh dealing with
difficult situations that was not his
Forte and I think that was really one of
the the reasons why he decided
um when he did to step down that he
really felt he could no longer govern
the church uh given the the scale of the
challenge that was needed and so
I think that that decision he took
um in 2013 to resign
um it was a decision that was not
totally unprecedented in church history
you have to remember the Catholic church
it's a church that thinks in centuries
there was clearly a provision for it in
the church's law that a pope could step
down Benedict XVI had seen John Paul II
um in his final days very unwell and
he's seen some of the difficulties that
that had caused
um a kind of a power vacuum that was
created by uh when a pope is unable or
physically unable to to carry out all
his all his duties so I think he wanted
to avoid that and when he resigned so he
he took that that very very bold
decision
um but it I think we see in Benedict
that tension between someone who
uh is is reform-minded but also someone
who
um you know wishes also to make ensure
that things don't go too far I suppose
maybe all of us have that tension within
us or or all believers have that tension
between the desire to maintain what we
have but also realize that reform is
necessary
well it does leave the church in the
rather interesting position now doesn't
it because it's
normally when a pope dies you have a
conclave you have a to a let's say you
pull but now it's it it's rather tricky
isn't it because we're still waiting on
details from the Vatican and what will
happen of course but
um it does seem sort of procedurally we
are in rather Uncharted Territory now
we are
um because uh Benedict's funeral uh
arrangements are not clear
um there is a very clear set of
procedures when a serving Pope dies that
kick into place but it's less clear
um for for Benedict now the Vatican have
announced that from Monday there will be
a lying in state of benedictines and
Peter's Basilica so
people can pay their respects
um we don't know how long that's going
to last for
um but that is something that's already
been announced I think a lot will depend
both on what Pope Francis decides to do
and what Benedict has stipulated if he
has stipulated
okay and so I think that's what we'll
have to to see play out well that's what
we will we will wait for and as soon as
we have those details of course we'll
bring them to you here on Sky News but
Christopher Lam for now rule
correspondent for the tablet uh great to
get your thoughts and Analysis thank you
very much indeed uh we can speak now to
Madeleine T Han she's the former
associate editor of the Catholic Heralds
uh Madeline good to have you with us
we're just hearing there we are rather
in it in Uncharted Territory for the
Catholic church and certainly for for
believers this is a very sad day isn't
it
it's an incredibly uh sad day I I myself
feel very very moved um and obviously I
think especially for Catholics in the UK
they have a special connection with
Benedict because of course due to his
papal visit in 2010 and um as I think
um Chris Lam alluded to expectation was
that it might not it might not go so
well especially after you know the
Charisma and popularity of John Paul II
and in fact you know Benedict arrived
and it was a fantastic
um event
um and you know I think he surprised us
and I think he has surprises ever since
the beginning of his papacy
what stands out to you because we the
the the
I thought to generalize but but
certainly it was a short papacy he was
viewed as being very conservative you
know a German Pope the first German Pope
in a thousand years and it was seen as
somewhat difficult to Outsiders I mean
that doesn't tally with with your
Recollections of his papacy how was it
for you
um I think for me he was
um the his papal Legacy was very much
the The Bridge Over Troubled Water
um he guided the church from the era of
John Paul II which had many great things
but also I think at the time of John
Paul's passing there was obviously a lot
of focus on um clerical sexual abuse and
he guided the church from from that to
the era of Francis and in fact he said
he chose the name Benedict because
Benedict XV had steered the church
through the turmoil during World War One
so for me Benedict was actually he was a
stabilizing influence but also he
brought through his sort of you know
academic um Talent he's great mind his
clear thinking he brought so much
Clarity
um at a time where I think that the
church was a little bit lost and you
know the world was a little bit lost he
spoke with such Clarity he did this
amazing address
um at Westminster Hall when he came in
2000 110 and he in that gentle but firm
and so clear way he talked about the
importance of religion in the Public
Square about you know its importance in
terms of what it could contribute the
good it could do when I think at the
time
um religion was
you know was very much in in some
aspects um under attack from sort of
more sort of modern uh secular ideas and
Benedict just very firmly very politely
and with a humility affirmed its place
and I don't think we can you know we
can't overestimate the value of him so
so for me that's how I will remember him
uh for somebody for that you know that
the Bridge Over Troubled Water the man
who guided us from from John Paul II to
Francis but also a man with a great
great mind
um who did actually a significant amount
for the church in a very short time
he was a man with a great minds and he
was he described almost as more of an
administrator really more of a scholar
than
a pope do you think there was a tension
there that that he himself felt that
perhaps he would would be better served
by continuing with studies rather
described himself as just sort of the
humble worker in the vineyard everyone
when he was elected
no this is the chap he was once referred
to as you know God's Rottweiler and he
said no I'm I'm the humble worker in the
vineyard so that's quite a contrast and
I think there was attention I think he
did he did crave for the for a quieter
more cerebral sort of existence and I
think that you know ultimately he had
the humility to know his limits and when
he realized that he just did not feel
well enough I think I mean it was sort
of Health grounds were sort of uh cited
as part of the reason he may have
resigned that he was able to hold up his
hands and say I can't do this to the
best of my ability anymore and I think
there certainly was attention and I
think you know if you look at the place
where he spent his final years
um a monastery he wanted that choir he
wanted that reflection okay
uh I'm I'm terribly sorry to cut you off
there Madeline and but we are we are
running short on time but thank you so
much for joining us here on Sky News and
and sharing your thoughts uh and
Recollections of Pope Benedict the 16th
let's take you now to Westminster
Cathedral uh roscoes Malena vasilinovich
is uh joins us now and it's quite a
poignant day for Catholics really
um isn't it
indeed well we're at Westminster
cathedral which is the mother Church of
the Catholic Church here in England and
in Wales and we spoke to the faithful as
they went into the cathedral my math
started at 10 30. most of them had not
heard the news
um they were of course very saddened by
it a lot of them remembering the visit
of Pope Benedict in 2010. now what was
interesting also is that considering
that this is the main Church in the
country there weren't that many people
who were attending mass and I'd say the
majority of them were actually Brazilian
and in a way that does reflect what
we've been seeing in the past few years
a decline in attendance in Western
Europe a growth in attendance in places
like Latin America but of course a big
historic figure who has perished okay
thank you very much Molina
professinovich stay with us on Sky News
we'll have more on the death of the
former Pope after this
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is Sky News at 11 the breaking news
this morning
former Pope Benedict XVI has died at the
age of 95.
the former Pope's death comes almost a
decade after he stood down due to poor
health
the Vatican has said Emeritus Benedict's
body will lie in state for Monday in
Saint Peter's Basilica
[Music]
our top story this morning tributes are
being paid to former Pope Benedict XVI
he died this morning aged 95. in 2013
Pope Benedict became the first pontiff
to resign in 600 years saying he no
longer had the physical and mental
strength to run the church the head of
the Catholic church in England's
Cardinal Vincent Nichols has said Pope
Benedict was one of the great
theologians of the 20th century our
Europe correspondent Siobhan Robbins
looks back at his life and Legacy
he was known as the intellectual Pope
the son of a policeman a child who lived
through Nazi rule in 2005 Cardinal
Joseph ratzinger became Benedict XVI the
first German to be elected Pope in a
thousand years
an uncompromising theological
conservative Cardinals chose him as a
safe Pair of Hands
Benedict Was a shy person he loved books
he loved his desk writing reflecting
bringing in beautiful German and then
also in other languages his thought but
a lonely person
he was even telling people my true
friends are the books
nickname God's rottweiler for his
uncompromising conservative views is a
cardinal at times his eight-year papacy
was marked by missteps the
rehabilitation of a holocaust denier
angering Jews a clumsy speech
antagonizing Muslims
but many respected his deep faith
his strength was clearly how to express
the Christian faith in a way
understandable to Modern human beings
that's
his message that's what he leaves us
among Catholics Benedict Was widely
popular in 2010 he made the first ever
papal State visit to the UK welcome by a
crowd of adoring pilgrims
before meeting Queen Elizabeth
politicians and giving dozens of sermons
but his visit was controversial for
critics who claimed he was not doing
enough to tackle sex abuse in the church
a topic which would haunt him into his
retirement
the number one challenge for Pope
Benedict Was the abuse crisis which was
just gaining it in in speed and
spreading all over the world during his
pontificate and he did take several
steps to begin to respond to that but
his critics say that he he didn't do
enough in the time that he was the pope
in 2013 tired by a Vatican League
Scandal and dogged by ill health
benedict made history again
this time becoming the first pope in 600
years to resign
in his final address to the faithful
he acknowledged the weight of the office
and the church's problems
it was a journey with joy and light but
there have also been difficult moments
than in an extraordinary chapter for the
Catholic church he said goodbye to the
Cardinals before retiring to a monastery
in Vatican City
that was a remarkable step he made and
there hadn't been a pop since the Middle
Ages though who stepped down so he as a
fairly conservative person was also
opening a door
to a world of today where people need
not to stay in office until they die
after retirement Benedict chose to keep
wearing white give interviews and not
revert his old name decisions critics
claimed threatened the unity in the
church
but the two popes personal relationship
was strong France is referring to his
predecessor as a grandfather figure and
asking people to pray for his friend as
his health deteriorated
he's very sick he told worshipers in
December asking the Lord to comfort him
to the very end
today Benedict is remembered again as
millions of Catholics around the world
pray for the man who led their church
for almost a decade
Sky News
[Applause]
well Sky events commentator Aleister
Bruce joins me now on the phone and
Alistar this really is the Catholic
church in almost Uncharted Territory now
because
Pope Emeritus Benedict has no past but
there is still another Pope in place
well I think the REM Catholic Church
would say that it's very steady because
since Francis the first was selected as
he has been the Supreme pontiff and
Benedict very effectively pulled himself
out of public life it's a moment when
that could be a reflection on the very
brief pontificate of Benedict XVI but he
was 95 and he had lived a fascinating
life a brief pontificate that was very
controversial but he had started his
life in Munich he had lived through the
period of Adolf Hitler he'd been swept
up and caught in the difficulties that
any young child would have during that
very difficult time for Germany and he
followed his faith very
carefully and steadily but I think that
he found the pontificate too much for
him because of the controversies that he
faced and that the church was struggling
to deal with and it wasn't able to deal
with it at the speed that the world
wanted and I think that Benedict XVI who
had sought after John Paul II died to
carry the Roman Catholic Church back to
more traditional practices was out
maneuvered by the events of the world
and I think in his isolated time
following his retirement he dedicates
himself to prayer and to the support of
Pope Francis
well you mentioned though the the the
scandals that dogged his his brief
papacy there were of course
challenges facing the the ongoing child
abuse scandals but also allegations he'd
antagonized other
other religions
well in the end the pope will always be
a focus
of tremendous challenge because whatever
popes decide will affect Christians all
over the world and other faiths I think
that the difficulty he faced most
particularly was that this sex abuse had
been going on in the church for
Generations but the attitudes of the
world had changed and he was not perhaps
the leader equipped to manage quickly
and effectively and forthrightly for the
Roman Catholic Church the the impact of
the reality of how big the problem had
been and was and perhaps still is and it
was that I think that in the end
perhaps made him with his reducing
Health feel he was unable to carry out
this immense office and of course if you
are at the head of the REM Catholic
church and you follow somebody as world
famous as John Paul II had become it was
always going to perhaps be quite
challenging for him anyway it was quite
Brave to summon up something that hadn't
been done for about six centuries and
abdicate from the role and then leave
your successor to carry on in your Stead
we've had commentators this morning
Alistair claiming that he
he saw his role as being something of a
bridge really to help guide the Catholic
Church from the immense popularity of
John Paul II to Pope Francis is that
something that you would perhaps agree
with
well I think he found himself in a
position of leadership when John Paul II
died because he was Dean of the College
of cardinals which meant that he was as
it were the leader of all those
Cardinals who gathered to choose John
Paul II successor and there were what
are known as per pabele who are
cardinals who are deemed to be possible
candidates but in the end I think that
because it was such a long time since
the Cardinals had gathered to elect a
new pope they saw the leadership that
Cardinal ratzinger as Benedict XVI was
then called was showing and they chose
him to be their leader whether he
thought of himself as a bridge at that
time I don't know after all the whole
title of Pope is Ponte which means
Bridge from you know the understanding
on Earth to the belief in Christ and
Christianity but whatever he did he did
become that bridge because the reforming
Zeal that we have witnessed in France's
also created a sort of reaction in some
Roman Catholics who cleaved hold of the
traditionalism of Benedict XVI and there
was during Benedict xvi's later time a
sort of division for some Catholics they
still saw him as the real Pope but he
has died today at the end of a very long
life in which I am sure that in every
way he has tried to serve
absolutely and and just finally Aleister
we're talking a lot about
how he was the first pope and 600 years
to
to resign but but how will you view his
legacy
well I'm speaking to you from Edinburgh
and it was to Edinburgh that he came in
2010 at the start of his papal visit to
the United Kingdom
and the effect that was achieved in
again the Lee of the life of John Paul
II was quite intense John Paul II had
visited the United Kingdom but not
Scotland in 1982 and Scotland has its
own Traditions there are divisions up
here between Catholic and non-catholic
that have sort of remained part of
Scottish life and I think that to a
great degree his impact here and when he
toured the United Kingdom was profound
he was present to beatify as somebody
who'd started his life as an Anglican
and became a very significant Roman
Catholic called Cardinal now Blessed
John Newman and all these impacts were
very great and part of what he saw as
his contribution as a steadying
traditionalist who sought to cleave to
the Latin Mass which was a way in which
Catholics across the world would join
together in the same language of Rome
from ancient times and I think he was
probably outmaneuvered by almost
everything that was going on around him
and his health also meant that he
decided to stand down but we remember
now a very brief pontificate but an
extraordinary decision to step down from
such a high office the first person to
do it for 600 years
okay Alistair Bruce there as Sky events
commentator speaking to us from
Edinburgh there thank you very much
indeed
and they were just hearing confirmation
from the Vatican there that Pope Francis
will celebrate the funeral for his
predecessor Pope Benedict's on January
5th in Saint Peter's Square
Let's uh take you now to uh Adam Parsons
or our Europe correspondents uh and Adam
we got the news
an hour or so ago just over an hour ago
that's uh Pope Benedict uh had died he
was a very old Pope who's one of the
eldest popes elected really so this
wasn't really a surprise but but still
it will be quite affecting news for it
for Catholics not just across Europe
across the world
yeah and the Catholic church around the
world has about 1.2 1.3 billion
followers so if it was a country it
would only be marginally smaller than
China and when I look uh around Europe
you see countries like uh it is 94 of
the Spanish population for instance are
Catholics uh similarly if you look in
Italy it's about 88 more than half the
people in France uh are Catholics and
then you look at Brazil where there are
huge numbers about 160 billion people
say they are Catholics 100 million or so
in Mexico so this will come as a as a
very very sad announcement people here
in Europe and indeed around the world a
shock no not really because uh this were
the pope Emeritus was 95 years old the
longest living pope in history now of
course there's a slight caveat to that
is that he wasn't Pope when he died the
first man for hundreds of years to had
retired as Pope and of course that
action has so many things that happened
during Benedict's Reign was pretty
divisive there were those who were
frankly appalled that somebody did not
see this as a job for Life there were
those who I think were stunned even by
the method by which he retired he made
his announcement in Latin and as he made
that announcement there were Cardinals
listening who didn't really understand
what he said and there was famously only
one journalist who was listening in and
spoke fluent Latin and who actually
understood the gravity of what had been
announced at that time so I think
Benedict will go down as a a very
unusual character remember this was a
man who was an academic more than
anything far more experience of of being
a theologian and an academic a professor
then he did have of being a pastoral
priest and he said in later life that
the books were his friends when he was
appointed priest his entire study was
taken from his office and moved Lock
Stock into his papal headquarters and he
once described books as not just being
his friends but being his community he
said he knew every nook and cranny of
them and I think he came to realize that
being an academic wasn't necessarily the
best preparation for being the leader of
the entire Catholic world he was to
reflect later that he wasn't great at
making decisions and I think that
perhaps came to slightly Cloud his time
as papacy you may remember in later
times we had the Vata link Scandal where
a butler in the Vatican City had leaked
a whole series of documents from an
Italian journalist because he said he
thought there was corruption and evil
happening that that the Pope wasn't able
to grasp wasn't aware of they are that
of course the second Scandal of his
papacy the first was that question about
whether he had done enough to confront
child sexual abuse and indeed whether he
as the bishop of Munich had himself done
a nut an African confront that and I
think by Common consent it was in in a
sense an epiphany of his own during his
papacy I think to grasp just how deep
just how damaging this had been he five
times met survivors of childhood sexual
abuse and was clearly seen sobbing on
occasions he he used to wait until
Friday morning to read through these
accounts and described it as being his
own Penance and I think it was that that
led him to the retirement and then this
sort of interregnum that we've had for
the past decade where he maintained the
name of Benedict of course he was
Cardinal ratzinger Joseph ratson a
normal life he continued to wear papal
vestments he continued to live in the
Vatican and I think there were some
conservative elements particularly
within the Catholic Church who saw him
as a as a lightning rod I wonder now
that he has gone whether or not uh Pope
Francis will be seen more as the
Undisputed leader of the Catholic church
and certainly seen as uh as a more
liberal voice compared to some of
Benedict's more conservative
pronouncements those debates all to come
we understand now this funeral will be
held on on January the 5th so that is
only five days from now a relatively
relatively predictable time frame but
only because we had heard it would be
between four and six days the protocol
for what to do when a retired Pope dies
is not laid down to extent the Vatican
is now showing us something that we have
never seen before Pope has been so many
centuries until the pope died and there
wasn't an appointment of a replacement
at the same time that we are entering a
new phase of what I think the expression
Uncharted Territory is going to crop up
again and again today but more than
anything it is a day when more than a
billion Catholics around the world as
well as observers will be will be
remembering the life of Benedict already
warm words here in Europe being
expressed by a Manuel macron the
president of France from Georgia Maloney
in Italy all of Schultz chancellor of
Germany all remembering this this
extremely powerful uh figure who led the
church and then did that thing that
hadn't been done for centuries and
decided to retire
we will have days and days in our head
of I think remembering Benedict deciding
upon his legacy and saying what this
means for the church going forward okay
Adam Parsons there are you repetitor
joining his life from Brussels thank you
very much indeed
Adam Let's uh speak now with Kaya
Burgess who covers science and religion
for the times and uh he joins us now uh
okay we're just hearing from our Europe
editor that this is very much a a new
phase for the Catholic church and very
unusual circumstances indeed this is
very sad of course
for Catholics but
fascinating time given the fact that uh
we're talking about a retired Pope who
has died and not a serving one
well that's exactly right I mean if you
go back six seven hundred years it
wasn't even that uncommon for popes to
step down or be deposed in by a sort of
armed forces but of course for 600 years
popes have served until their death
which means that for centuries there's
been a very set process that the
Catholic church that the Vatican goes
through on the death of a pope in terms
of who announces the death who
officiates at the funeral the destroying
of the papal ring a certain type of
lying in state happens and then of
course usually it's a figure called the
kamalengo who's like a a sort of
caretaker in the Vatican who serves
until the Cardinals come together to
elect a new pope and the smoke out of
the chimney and all that that we're
familiar with of course none of that
really needs to happen because we have a
a current and serving Pope and so it's
really interesting to see what the
Vatican will say about the the process
they're going to go through is presumed
that Pope Francis himself will preside
over the funeral whereas Norm normally
it's one of the kind of cardinals during
the interregnum but we don't know if
will Pope Benedict be laid in state in
the sort of red vestments as the hopes
usually are will there be an official
nine-day morning period as there usually
is will there be a funeral where world
leaders from around the globe are
invited in the same way these are the
things we're still waiting to hear
because as for 600 years this happened
hasn't happened and when it did last
happen the role of Pope was a very
different one in the in the 15th century
indeed we are started starting to get
some details uh through the okaya uh the
Vatican saying that uh he will start
lying in States I believe from the sixth
I beg your pardon uh January 5th is when
Pope Francis will celebrate at the
funeral for
um Benedict XVI and that will be in
Saint Peter's square but lots of details
still to be to be worked out here it
will also be fascinating will it not
just to see how the church moves forward
after this because it was a short papacy
but it was it was certainly one that was
was very distinct when you think he he
forwards Pope John Paul II he was
enormously popular
um and now we have Pope Francis the
serving Pope who who's I don't want to
say politics but he seems to be rather
more on the liberal end of the spectrum
than the conservative and traditional
tradition and that that certainly
Benedict XVI will be remembered for
yeah that's true that's what's been
particularly fascinating about having
these two living popes together is the
knowledge that Benedict you know he had
a role for a long time before becoming
pope of being essentially the catholic's
church sort of Doctrine policeman I mean
he was in charge of kind of protecting
the doctrine of the church and and
keeping it sort of Traditional Values
ratzinger himself Benedict himself was
seen as something of a liberal until the
60s when various um parts of Catholic
teaching were challenged and then he
became much more of a conservative and
and Pope Francis is seen as more of a
liberal I mean that that's still within
the Fairly strict confines of Catholic
church doctrine and so there haven't
been any huge changes under Francis they
haven't allowed women to become priests
or change their teaching on same-sex
marriage and so on but it felt like Pope
Francis was more open to those sorts of
ideas being a little bit more welcoming
backing for example allowing remarried
divorces to take communion in church
which Benedict kind of made kind of
quite clear in the background that he
wasn't a fan of so I don't know if that
means that Pope Francis will feel a
little Freer in some of his liberal
views or perhaps the conservatives will
be stronger in their opposition to him
because they no longer have Benedict as
a as a focal point for that well it is
rather fascinating isn't it I mean it's
a speculation at this point but
where do you see the church going from
here is it likely to be more more united
because there are these distinct
factions aren't they the more the more
liberal and and the more conservative
factions of the church which have rather
been at loggerheads really during this
era of the the two popes
I don't think that will change honestly
I mean what's really interesting I think
for the Catholic Church going forward is
Will Benedict's resignation set more of
a precedent because
um in terms of Bishops and archbishops
the Catholic Church sets a retirement
age of 75 and that's when you sort of
automatically retire unless you're given
permission to kind of keep serving
whereas Pope is the only role that it's
it's until death and when Benedict
stepped down and the Archbishop of
Canterbury has said today he describes
it as a a courageous and humble decision
from Benedict to have steps down and
Pope Francis has hinted quite heavily
that he would consider resigning himself
if he felt that his health
was preventing him from fulfilling the
role as fully as he might like and he
has I mean he's got mobility issues at
the moment he's struggled to make some
foreign trips because I think he's got a
knee problem and so on and so it would
be very interesting to see if Francis
takes the same step and as for therefore
the division between conservatives and
liberals with that in mind uh I think
there'll still be that jockeying between
well who's going to who will replace
Pope Francis when he dies or retires and
will it be a more conservative voice
will it be a more liberal voice will it
be someone that France is a slightly
kind of either molded In His Image or
sees as following in his school or will
it be someone a bit more like Benedict
so I don't I don't think there's much
chance of those uh of those divisions
going away okay
uh Kaya Burgess there uh correspondent
for the times on religion and science uh
great to get your analysis thank you
very much indeed
Let's uh take you know to Westminster
Cathedral where Sky's Molina
veselinovich is standing by and Molina
this is a very sad day for Catholics
isn't it
certainly well the Westminster Cathedral
is the seat of the Catholic church in
England and Wales the mass here has just
finished and we spoke to people coming
out who told us that at the end of it it
was announced that the former Pope
Benedict had died in a prayer was said
in his memory it came as a surprise to
most people that we spoke to who said
they hadn't really realized that he was
that ill and he certainly made an
impression on the congregation here we
spoke to a woman who had come to see him
as he held a public prayer in London in
2010 and she had been in atheist prior
to that and she said that she was so
moved that it compelled her to embrace
Catholicism so it was certainly a very
sad day for her we spoke to another
woman who said that she certainly
remembers him fondly because of she said
the kind of correct path that he took in
terms of leading the Catholic church and
there were also people here from Spain
and for Brazil where the Catholic church
is very strong perhaps even stronger
than here in Western Europe but yes
generally tint with sadness and
certainly all of the people that we
spoke to here said that they will be
keeping the former Pope Benedict in
their prayers
and is there certainly the news is still
very much sinking in Molina
um the news broke this morning around
around half past nine local time of
course in the Vatican where people put
Benedict Was we are starting to get
these announcements about the funeral
from from the Vatican but are you seeing
more people coming to the cathedral to
pay their respects as this news starts
to to filter Downs Awards uh towards the
the public
well certainly there are masses planned
throughout the day today and the
congregation coming here they're very
regular they come every Saturday it was
news to pretty much everyone we spoke to
that the pope had passed the former Pope
had passed away but certainly as the day
progresses we can expect more mourners
to come here which is really the mother
Church of the Catholic church in this
country and we've seen reaction of
course from many figures so far the head
of the Catholic Church here in the UK
but also the Prime Minister Rishi sunak
also reflecting on that visit by the
former Pope in 2010 when he celebrated a
public mass in Glasgow but he also held
prayers and a vigil with the Archbishop
of Canterbury here in London and that
was the point in women for many of the
people who came to mass here today what
was quite interesting is that there were
lots of people also from Spain who said
they would be definitely watching the
funeral they were asking us about the
details of it because of course the news
is still trickling out and no one would
really go into kind of any comparisons
between the former Pope and Pope Francis
he was seen as the leader of what is one
of the most powerful organizations in
the world and I think that you would
expect the people who come here to
church fairly regularly would have I say
followed the doctrine and the philosophy
of whoever is leading that organization
at that point I think that they were all
quite curious to see if the passing of
Pope Benedict would have any influence
as to how Pope Francis decides to carry
on with his duties as we said we think
he's also reaching quite senior age he
is having issues traveling as well and
that was one of the reasons why Benedict
decided to retire and that really really
marked the uh his his
a sort of length of time that he was in
that role people remembering him as the
first and yet only for over the 600
years to resign but lots of thoughts
about him today prayers as well
inovich joining us from outside
Westminster Cathedral this morning thank
you Molina
well let's uh take you now to a reminder
of our breaking news this morning that
is of course Pope Benedict's a pope Ben
Pope Emeritus Benedict XVI has of course
died this morning he had been very ill
for a while of course a short papacy of
eight years our Europe correspondents
Siobhan Robbins takes a look back now at
his life and Legacy
he was known as the intellectual Pope
the son of a policeman a child who lived
through Nazi rule in 2005 Cardinal
Joseph ratzinger became Benedict XVI the
first German to be elected Pope in a
thousand years
an uncompromising theological
conservative Cardinals chose him as a
safe Pair of Hands
Benedict Was a shy person he loved books
he loved his desk writing reflecting
bringing in beautiful German and then
also in other languages his thought but
a lonely person
he was even telling people my true
friends are the books
nickname God's rottweiler for his
uncompromising conservative views is a
cardinal at times his eight-year papacy
was marked by missteps the
rehabilitation of a holocaust denier
angering Jews a clumsy speech
antagonizing Muslims
but many respected his deep faith
his strength was clearly how to express
the Christian faith in a way
understandable to Modern human beings
that's
his message that's what he leaves us
among Catholics Benedict Was widely
popular in 2010 he made the first ever
papal State visit to the UK welcome by a
crowd of adoring pilgrims
before meeting Queen Elizabeth
politicians and giving dozens of sermons
but his visit was controversial for
critics who claimed he was not doing
enough to tackle sex abuse in the church
a topic which would haunt him into his
retirement
the number one challenge for Pope
Benedict Was the abuse crisis which was
just gaining it in in speed and
spreading all over the world during his
pontificate and he did take several
steps to begin to respond to that but
his critics say that he he didn't do
enough in the time that he was a pope
in 2013 tired by a Vatican League
Scandal and dogged by ill health
benedict made history again
this time becoming the first pope in 600
years to resign
in his final address to the faithful
he acknowledged the weight of the office
and the church's problems
it was a journey with joy and light but
there have also been difficult moments
[Applause]
than in an extraordinary chapter for the
Catholic church he said goodbye to the
Cardinals before retiring to a monastery
in Vatican City
that was a remarkable step he made and
there hadn't been a pop since the Middle
Ages though who stepped down so he as a
fairly conservative person was also
opening a door
to a world of today where people need
not to stay in office until they die
after retirement Benedict chose to keep
wearing white give interviews and not
revert to his old name decisions critics
claimed threatened the unity in the
church
but the two popes personal relationship
was strong France is referring to his
predecessor as a grandfather figure and
asking people to pray for his friend as
his health deteriorated
he's very sick he told worshipers in
December asking the Lord to comfort him
to the very end
today Benedict is remembered again as
millions of Catholics around the world
pray for the man who led their church
for almost a decade
Robbins Sky News
well the tributes for the former Pope
have been pouring in
the Prime Minister Rishi sinak has
tweeted I'm saddened to learn of the
death of Pope Emeritus Benedict XVI he
was a great Theologian whose UK visit in
2010 was an historic moments for both
Catholics and non-catholics throughout
our country
my thoughts are with Catholic people in
the UK and around the world today
Cardinal Vincent Nichols the head of the
Roman Catholic Church in England and
Wales tweeted saying I am deeply
saddened to learn of the death of Pope
Benedict he will be remembered as one of
the great theologians of the 20th
century I remember with particular
affection the remarkable people visit to
these lands in 2010
the labor leader Sakira starmer has said
I'm sorry to hear of the death of Pope
Emeritus Benedict his State visits in
2010 was a historic and joyous moment
for Catholics in Britain may he rest in
peace
and we're also just hearing from the
leader of the Catholic church in Ireland
Eamonn Martin who has said that he's
saddened to hear of the death of Pope
Benedict and in a statements the
Archbishop of Omar said at this time of
mourning in the Catholic Church
throughout the world we remember his
gentle soul in prayer asking gods in his
great Mercy to forgive his sins and
human feelings while rewarding generous
service and complete dedication to the
gospel and to the church
well there is Skye's events commentator
Alistair Bruce reflected on Pope
Benedict's career I think he found
himself in a position of leadership when
John Paul II died because he was Dean of
the College of cardinals which meant
that he was as it were the leader of all
those Cardinals who gathered to choose
John Paul II successor and there were
what are known as Papale who are
cardinals who are deemed to be possible
candidates but in the end I think that
because it was such a long time since
the Cardinals had gathered to elect a
new pope they saw the leadership that
Cardinal ratzinger as Benedict XVI was
then called was showing and they chose
him to be their leader whether he
thought of himself as a bridge at that
time I don't know after all the whole
title of Pope is Ponte which means
Bridge from you know the understanding
on Earth to the belief in Christ and
Christianity but whatever he did he did
become that bridge because the reforming
Zeal that we have witnessed in Francis
also created a sort of reaction in some
REM Catholics who cleaved hold of the
traditionalism of Benedict xvi's and
there was during Benedict xvi's later
time a sort of division for some
Catholics they still saw him as the real
Pope but he has died today at the end of
a very long life in which I am sure that
in every way he has tried to serve I
think that to a great degree his impact
here and when he toured the United
Kingdom was profound he was present to
bayatify as somebody who'd started his
life as an Anglican and became a very
significant Roman Catholic called
Cardinal now Blessed John Newman and all
these impacts were very great and part
of what he saw as his contribution as a
steadying traditionalist who sought to
cleave to the Latin Mass which was a way
in which Catholics across the world
would join together in the same language
of Rome from ancient times and I think
he was probably outmaneuvered by almost
everything that was going on around him
and his health also meant that he
decided to stand down but we remember
now a very brief pontificate but an
extraordinary decision to step down from
such a high office the first person to
do it for 600 years
well if you're just joining us here on
Sky news this morning we have been
covering the news that the pope Emeritus
Benedict XVI has died
he of course was the first pope in 600
years to resign from the post rather
than rule for life he was one of the
eldest popes ever elected at the age of
78
and he lives until
the age of 95 so he was the the first
German to open a thousand years to be
elected
in
2005. a difficult act to follow really
he he succeeded the worldly popular John
Paul the the second who reigned for 27
years and
Pope Benedict xvi's papacy was was
rather shorter in comparison at only
eight years he stood down of course
citing ill health saying he didn't feel
able to continue uh in the role and was
succeeded by the current pope of course
Francis the first now Pope Francis has
said that he will hold the funeral for
the pope Emeritus Benedict XVI on
January 5th that will be held of course
in Saint Peter's Square so Pope Francis
is set to celebrate the funeral of his
predecessor Pope Benedict's on January
5th we are of course awaiting more
details from the Vatican as to what will
happen this is a very unusual situation
of course given that uh normally when a
pope dies there is a whole ceremony to
elect the successor of course this is
not uh the case now because Pope Francis
is the serving Pope it's a very unusual
situation for the Catholic Church let's
see if we can speak now to Cardinal
Vince Nichols he's the heads of the
Catholic church in England and Wales and
it's good to have you with us here on
Sky News this is a very sad day of
course
for for followers of the Catholic church
this morning but also very unusual
situation that the church finds itself
in isn't it yes you're correct your
comments are absolutely accurate uh it's
it's a sad day it's a day that would
inevitably come and once we had that
news last week uh or earlier this week
um that that the pope was declining in
health Pope Benedict then I think it was
just a matter of time
um and I think Catholics know now what
to do we we have a great tradition of
praying for the dead praying for those
who have died that God will receive them
mercifully into his presence I heard a
lovely comment from Rome just a few days
ago when one of the people there said as
as Pope Bendix Health declined so
rapidly he said the angels are gathering
to carry him home and that's what we
know today and we ask God to receive him
gratefully because he was a very
faithful servant of the Church of Christ
throughout his life
how would you define his legacy Cardinal
Nichols
well I think there are three aspects to
it actually I mean the first is he was a
remarkable Theologian a thinker somebody
who wanted to explore what faith in God
or what faith in Jesus Christ meant and
he had both an immense intellectual
grasp of those issues but also a
gentleness and a Clarity of expression
which meant that he unlike many
theologians his writing was very
accessible and inspirational so he
published two big volumes on the life of
Jesus of Nazareth which both explored
critical
issues of scriptural scholarship but
also opened up the life of Jesus to
anybody who wanted to explore it a bit
more so a great Theologian one of the
great theologians of the 20th century
secondly again given his background and
his life experience more than any other
Pope he understood
democracy and the importance of
democracy and the challenges that
democracy faces and he called
insistently for a dialogue between the
world of reason and the world of Faith
he did that most eloquently here in
London in 2010 when he addressed the
grace and the good assembled in
Westminster Hall and he talked about his
esteem for British democracy and its
institutions but also its challenges how
do we come to know what is of moral
imperative where do we get our deepest
values from and his challenge was that
if they come no more than from a social
consensus then that's a real challenge
democracy which can be abused and I
think as he saw that in his own country
of Germany all those decades ago and
then thirdly he struggled as we all have
done uh with the terrible business of
the sexual abuse of children by priests
I mean he was the one who actually set
the core the church on a course that we
now speak of as zero tolerance so when
for example he was in charge of the
doctrinal section of the Holy See he
personally instigated the layersization
of over 400 priests because they had
offended he was saying there's no place
for you here so I think that was a great
struggle for him but he brought those
two great gifts as a theologian and as
somebody who understood contemporary
European Society in particular
it's interesting you say that because
the the I guess in in wiser and popular
culture that that's not the image of the
of uh
Pope Benedict that that we have he was
seen as very certainly an academic but
certainly someone who was on the more
conservative side of things and the
scandals really did seem to
to dog him somewhat and it was a very
short papacy do you think history will
will end up being rather rather kinder
to him
well I I think the fact is that
categories of conservative and liberal
don't quite fit I mean what Pope
Benedict understood was if you like how
how our understanding of our faith and
the teaching of the church develops with
time and at the same time remains
faithful so he had those double concerns
of development and Fidelity now another
character who had those same concerns
was Colonel John Henry Newman the great
Victorian English Churchman who many
people hold up as a hero of a liberal
position and that too doesn't quite fit
Pope Benedict had enormous admiration
for John Henry Newman and he came to
this country when he came in 2010 one of
the main reasons was to declare John
Henry Newman to be a senate so John
Henry Newman popularly thought of as
liberal Pope Benedict popularly thought
of as conservative it just doesn't work
like that and I think both of them in
different ways had these same
preoccupations yes the church is
teaching and thought develops yes it
remains faithful to the sources that are
given uniquely in what we call the
Revelation given by Jesus Christ
um with one thing perhaps that the pope
will be the Pope Benedict rather will be
remembered for quite quite keenly is is
the fact that he did choose to resign he
choose he chose to to stand down
um which is
I don't want to say unprecedented but
the church does find itself in a rather
unusual situation doesn't it because
one Pope has died and we still have a
current serving Pope do you think that
complicates things rather or is this a
sign of perhaps the church modernizing
in some way well I think that remains to
be seen quite frankly uh I I I I think
people were quite astonished when Pope
Benedict made that statement and I
remember it clearly it was to a group of
cardinals I was not there and he gave it
entirely in Latin which I think some of
them didn't really understand but when
the news broke it was a lot of
readjusting to be done and and I think
eventually people aren't mired if you
like his humility and his sense of the
burden of the papacy and that both with
circumstances his age and his health
this was not going to be a time
something that he could continue now
whether that happens again I've no more
idea than you I think the strong
tradition is that a pope is elected and
stays for Life unless it becomes
dramatically incompetent and I would
imagine that that tradition will hold
sway at least for the time being
okay we we do know now of course that uh
Pope Francis will celebrate the funeral
on the uh the 5th of January
this this truly will give Comfort to
Catholics at this time will they not of
course of course and and I will make
every effort to be there uh and as I say
in in the Catholic faith there is a
strong tradition that we pray for those
who have died our contact with them is
not broken it's changed you know in the
eyes of faith when a person dies life is
not ended but it's changed we go on to a
phase of life which is is its
fulfillment it's what we've been created
for is to be with God and so it's that
entry into the next phase of life that
we pray for Pope Benedict as well as
thanking God for the gifts which this
man brought in his life of service to
the church immense gifts very unique
gifts for which we are very very
grateful
okay Cardinal Vince Nichols head of the
Catholic church in England and Wales
thank you so much for joining us on Sky
news this morning thank you
uh well let's uh take you now uh to Rome
where we can speak with NBC News foreign
correspondent Claudio lavanger uh and he
joins us now we can see the the Basilica
in the background behind you there
Claudio
um just give us a sense of what the
atmosphere is like where you are because
of course the news people will have now
had
an hour so a couple of hours for that
news to sink in the death of the former
Pope Benedict XVI
hey Allah well yes the I think that
people are wearing are still unaware of
what's going on because if you go to
Saint Peter's Square uh this morning as
I was rushing here of course after the
news broke uh Saint Peter's square is
quite full of tourists and pilgrims who
just will go there anyway uh because of
the end of the year because these
holidays and they're all queuing to get
into uh Saint Peter's Basilica but
what's perhaps interesting and shocking
is how different people from around the
world perceive Pope Benedict 16 compared
to theologians and staunch Catholics I
mean just yesterday we were there in
Saint Peter Square asking people uh the
tourists and the pilgrims were just
lining to get into Saint Peter's
Basilica what they thought about the
fact that Pope Benedict was sick of
course this was yesterday and and to our
surprise uh several people didn't know
who he was others knew who he is but who
he was but they didn't know he was sick
and and several others like a third knew
about it and they were praying for him
so in a way that kind of is not of
course a scientific method but in a way
kind of it's the same it would probably
be the same atmosphere right now among
the pilgrims and tourists and who was
just lining up there to get into Saint
Peter's square but I can only imagine
that there will be staunch Catholics who
appreciated uh Pope Benedict 16 who will
be making their way if they are in Rome
of course here to pray in Saint Peter's
square right now for him Allah
yeah we um we we did have that live shot
up next to you just showing the people
starting to gather uh there uh in the
Vatican uh thank you so much indeed uh
that's our uh NBC News foreign
correspondent Claudio lavanga there just
setting the scene for us uh from Rome
let's stay with us uh joining us now is
Saba ahmedi uh oh I beg your pardon we
don't have Saba we do however uh we will
bring you more in the next hour on the
death of the former Pope Benedict uh who
has died this morning
um he will be remembered as among the
great popes uh he defended truth and
extolled the beauty of Holiness against
a sometimes hostile secular worlds uh
what I'm reading you now is actually
attributes uh from Jacob Reese morg MP
of course uh uh astonished Catholic
himself
um he has uh
said that Pope Benedict will be
remembered as among the great popes uh
Jacob reads smog going on to say he
defended truth and extored the beauty of
Holiness against us sometimes
hostile secular worlds as the successor
to Saint Peter he was a rock of Faith so
Jacob Reese smog there at his adding his
tribute to the former Pope and there
have been more tributes coming in the
Prime Minister Rishi sunak has also
tweeted earlier this morning saying that
I am saddened to learn of the death of
Pope Emeritus Bennett the 16th uh the
Prime Minister saying he was a great
Theologian whose UK visit in 2010 was an
historic moments for both Catholics and
non-catholics throughout the country
and he's saying his thoughts are with
Peace Catholic people in the UK and
around today we'll have more of those
tributes for you at the top of the air
to keep it here with us on Sky News
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is Sky News at midday the headlines
former Pope Benedict XVI has died at the
age of 95.
former Pope's death comes almost a
decade after he stood down due to poor
health
the Vatican has said Pope Emeritus
Benedict's body will lie in States for
Monday in Saint Peter's Basilica ahead
of his funeral on Thursday also today
some but not all of the lionesses are
recognized in the King's first New
Year's honors list
the government announces new covert
testing rules for anyone arriving in
England from China after a surge in
cases there
[Applause]
and New Year's Eve celebrations have
begun with fireworks and a light show in
Auckland New Zealand
s
[Music]
good afternoon tributes are being paid
to former Pope Benedict XVI who died
this morning age 95 in 2013 Pope
Benedicts became the first pontiff to
resign in 600 years saying he no longer
had the physical and mental strength to
run the church the head of the Catholic
church in England's Cardinal Vincent
Nichols has said Pope Benedict was one
of the great theologians of the 20th
century
we'll have more on the tribute side this
morning by the prime minister in a
moment first though our Europe
correspondent Siobhan Robbins looked
back at Benedict xvi's Life and Legacy
he was known as the intellectual Pope
the son of a policeman a child who lived
through Nazi rule in 2005 Cardinal
Joseph ratzinger became Benedict XVI the
first German to be elected Pope in a
thousand years
an uncompromising theological
conservative Cardinals chose him as a
safe Pair of Hands
Benedict Was a shy person he loved books
he loved his desk writing reflecting
bringing in beautiful German and then
also in other languages his thought but
a lonely person
he was even telling people my true
friends are the books
nicknamed God's rottweiler for his
uncompromising conservative views as a
cardinal at times his eight-year papacy
was marked by missteps the
rehabilitation of a holocaust denier
angering Jews a clumsy speech
antagonizing Muslims
but many respected his deep faith
his strength was clearly how to express
the Christian faith in a way
understandable to Modern human beings
that's
his message that's what he leaves us
among Catholics Benedict Was widely
popular in 2010 he made the first ever
papal State visit to the UK welcomed by
a crowd of adoring pilgrims
before meeting Queen Elizabeth
politicians and giving dozens of sermons
but his visit was controversial for
critics who claimed he was not doing
enough to tackle sex abuse in the church
a topic which would haunt him into his
retirement
the number one challenge for Pope
Benedict Was the abuse crisis which was
just gaining it in in speed and
spreading all over the world during his
pontificate and he did take several
steps to begin to respond to that but
his critics say that he he didn't do
enough in the time that he was a pope
in 2013 tired by a Vatican League
Scandal and dogged by ill health
benedict made history again
this time becoming the first pope in 600
years to resign
in his final address to the faithful
he acknowledged the weight of the office
and the church's problems
it was a journey with joy and light but
there have also been difficult moments
than in an extraordinary chapter for the
Catholic church he said goodbye to the
Cardinals before retiring to a monastery
in Vatican City
that was a remarkable step he made and
there hadn't been a pope since the
Middle Ages though who stepped down so
he as a fairly conservative person was
also opening a door
to a world of today where people need
not to stay in office until they die
after retirement Benedict chose to keep
wearing white give interviews and not
revert his old name decisions critics
claimed threatened the unity in the
church
but the two popes personal relationship
was strong France is referring to his
predecessor as a grandfather figure and
asking people to pray for his friend as
his health deteriorated
he's very sick he told worshipers in
December asking the Lord to comfort him
to the very end
today Benedict is remembered again as
millions of Catholics around the world
pray for the man who led their church
for almost a decade
Sky News
[Applause]
well let's get more now from NBC News
foreign correspondence Claudio lavanger
he joins us now from Rome and Claudio
this is certainly he was a very old man
the Pope Benedict the 16th so it's not
really a a surprises news but still a
shock nonetheless to the Catholic
Community
that's right holla well the pope when he
read the Pope Benedict 16 of course when
he retired in 2013 he said it was going
to kind of disappear from the eyes of
the world you know in a way he has
because he just hid into this remodel
Monastery in the Vatican behind me but
he has made some appearances
um on the upon the invitation of Pope
Francis to attend certain important
ceremonies and every time we saw him
let's say once or twice a year he looked
more and more frail and that of course
was really due to age lately the people
that managed to meet him in the
monastery he was receiving people when
you know he could
um told the press that he had lost his
voice but he was still very much Lucid
as the Vatican has said even yesterday a
couple of days ago during in a statement
following the Revelation that he was
very sick so he comes to nobody's
surprise of course that at that age
looking so frail and just slowly fading
away he has died but certainly still
comes as a shock to the many Catholics
around the world who got to know him to
go to love him to go to appreciate his
theology this is what most people who
are paying tributes this this day these
hours
um is uh they refer to that that he was
a great Theologian but as a matter of
fact this is kind of paves the way also
to what's going to happen in the future
because one of the greatest Legacy that
he left the pope ameritis is the fact
that he became the first pope to resign
after 600 years and Pope Francis has
said many many times that he will do the
same if he feels like that his health
does not will not allow him to carry on
to fulfill his ministry and as we know
just recently in the past couple of
weeks he gave an interview to Spanish
newspaper in which he said that he even
signed a resignation letter right away
in 2013 after he was elected where he
says that if my health for any reason I
am unable to continue in my pontificate
then then you should just use this
resignation letter so before while the
Pope Benedict was alive you know nobody
expected Pope Francis to resign of
course you can have three popes I mean
two are uh you know already a crowd uh
but what's going to happen now I mean
Pope Francis now is still Lucid he's
still uh you know very much healthy in a
way his main problem uh is that he's got
this big knee problem that makes it very
difficult for him to walk around but
what's going to happen in the next
months or or years uh if Pope Francis
feels like he just can't carry on so you
know we'll just do we'll have to wait
and see hello
will indeed Claudio lavanger NBC News
foreign correspondents live for us from
Rome thank you Claudia
well as we've been saying tributes for
the former Pope have been pouring in the
Prime Minister Rishi sunak tweeted
saying I am saddened to learn of the
death of Pope Emeritus Benedict the 16th
he was a great Theologian his UK visit
in 2010 was an historic moment for both
Catholics and non-catholics throughout
the country my thoughts are with
Catholic people in the UK and around the
world today the labor leader sakur
stormers said I am sorry to hear of the
death of Pope Emeritus Benedict State
visit in 2010 was a historic and joyous
moment for Catholics in Britain may he
rest in peace well the French President
Emmanuel macron has also tweeted saying
my thoughts go out to Catholics in
France and around the world bereaved by
the departure of his Holiness Benedict
XVI who works with soul and intelligence
for a more fraternal world
a conservative MP Jacob reese-mogg paid
tribute to the former Pope saying Pope
Benedicts will be remembered as among
the great popes he defended truth and
extolls the beauty of Holiness against a
sometimes hostile secular world as the
successor to Saint Peter he was a rock
of faith and his soul and The Souls of
all the faithful departed through the
mercy of God rest in peace
that was Jacob Reese mogg MP of course
ah very famously known as a Catholic in
the United Kingdom now in the past half
an hour we have also heard from Cardinal
Vincent Nichols the head of the woman
Catholic Church in England and Wales
it's a sad day it's a day that would
inevitably come and once we had that
news last week uh or earlier this week
um that that the pope was declining in
health Pope Benedict then I think it was
just a matter of time
um and I think Catholics know now what
to do we we have a great tradition of
praying for the dead praying for those
who have died that God will receive them
mercifully into his presence I heard a
lovely comment from Rome just a few days
ago when one of the people there said as
as Pope index Health declined so rapidly
he said the angels are gathering to
carry him home and that's what we know
today and we ask God to receive him
gratefully because he was a very
faithful servant of the Church of Christ
throughout his life in in the Catholic
faith there is a strong tradition that
we pray for those who have died our
contact with them is not broken that's
changed you know in the eyes of faith
when a person dies life is not ended but
it's changed we go on to a phase of life
which is is its fulfillment it's what
we've been created for is to be with God
and so it's that entry into the next
phase of life that we pray for Pope
Benedict as well as thanking God for the
gifts which this man brought in his life
of service to the church immense gifts
very unique gifts for which we are very
very grateful
the sky's Molina vasilinovich is outside
Westminster Cathedral for us this
morning of course that's the mother
church for Catholics in England and
Wales and Melina what reaction have you
been hearing there
well we spoke to people who had come out
of mass this morning they had been told
at the end of it that the former Pope
had passed away and there was a prayer
in his memory it came as a surprise to
everyone we spoke to they were aware of
his ill health but they had not yet
heard the news of his passing and many
were moved we spoke to a woman who was
actually encouraged to embrace
Catholicism after seeing the former Pope
Benedict during his visit to the UK in
2010 when he held a public vigil with
the Archbishop of Canterbury she said
that she was so taken by Emotion by what
she witnessed that she decided to
actually embrace Catholicism as her
religion we also spoke to people who had
come or here from Spain who go to church
regularly for them he was a stalworth of
Catholicism they thought that he had led
the church in what they described as a
correct way but in general as such a
powerful figurehead of an institution
that matters to billions of people
across the globe he will be remembered
throughout the day here at Westminster
Cathedral what is quite interesting is
that a lot of the people who had come to
mass here were actually from Latin
America and perhaps that in a way
reflects the burgeoning Catholicism in
that part of the world compared to what
it have been declining Church attending
rates in places like Western Europe but
it would be interesting to see if Pope
Francis who had taken slightly more
people would say progressive tone in his
tenure as Pope if the passing of Pope
Benedict who is more of a conservative
would lead Catholicism in perhaps a new
direction that is something that we
spoke to some of the people who were
here but for now thoughts and prayers
for him throughout the day and people
that we spoke to here say that they will
keep him in their thoughts
okay Melina faslinovich lifers from
Westminster Westminster Cathedral thank
you so much Melina let's bring you a
little bit of breaking news now from
Ukraine and several large explosions
have been felt in Kiev in the last few
minutes the city's mayor has just
confirmed the news on social media and
that confirmation came just a couple of
minutes after Air Raid Sirens sounded
right across Ukraine with officials
urging people to take cover bringing
more on that as we get it also this
lunchtime Vladimir Putin has been giving
his new year address he has been
accusing the west of cynically using
Ukraine to destroy Russia that New
Year's message from Vladimir Putin
coming of course just as those
explosions uh have been ringing across
out Kiev and the rest of the country
again keep an eye find that for you
bring you more as it comes in
now we've got a some more news for you
now and four of England's lionesses are
among those celebrated in the King's
first New Year's honors lists their
heads coach Serena viegman who's Dutch
has also been made an honorary CBE the
queen guitarist Brian May and the artist
Grayson Perry have both been knighted as
Skies Adele Robinson has been speaking
to some of the recipients foreign
the headline acts of the New Year honors
list
guitarist Brian May will be one of the
first to be knighted by the king I'm
thinking about my mum and my dad and how
they would be so happy and proud and
whatever because we all want to please
our mums and dads don't we and you know
it was a long road for me I displeased
them for some of my life
um so I think they'd be happy that I
landed up in this place but the other
thing I'm feeling very strongly is that
this is a kind of challenge it's taken
me to a new place and it's it's a kind
of commission I think that's the way I
regard it to do good in the world and do
better than I've done before
foreign
star to Lioness four England women
footballers on the Euro 2022 Winning
Side have been recognized and made mbes
one of them Lucy bronze it recognizes
all of the achievements put together and
says
yeah you've achieved so much both as an
individual and the team that you've
played in as a person
as a footballer
um and we recognize that and want to
celebrate your success and I guess
that's the way I see it is celebrating
everything together so I guess it goes
right to the top
England women's Coach Serena vegman's
also been given an order of the British
Empire
and another sporting Hero 2 Olympic gold
medalist Denise Lewis made a Dame it's
22 years ago since I won that gold medal
in in Sydney and uh so to be receiving
an Accolade as big as this
um it's almost more of a sweeter because
it isn't for my single performance it's
it's for service to the sport that has
given me so much
um it might be my life
among politicians honored Labor's Chris
Bryant Commons standards committee chair
will receive a Knighthood I just know so
many people in the Ronda who deserve
this so much more than I do nurses
carers you know posties bus drivers and
so on let alone other MPS which is a bit
more than I do so I was really really
shocked but most of the more than 1 000
recipients are lesser known like clean
air campaigner Rosamund whose
nine-year-old daughter Ella died from an
asthma attack and air pollution in 2013.
you know when Sadiq Khan keeps on saying
to me you're saving lives yes I know but
I I want especially with asthma I want
children to stop dying because I know in
Scandinavian countries children don't
really die from massive and that's
really what I want for children in this
country
an honors list that nods to some highs
and lows of recent years celebrating
both sung and unsung heroes Adele
Robinson Sky News
let's take a look at some of the day's
other news now and the American
broadcaster and pioneering TV
interviewer Barbara Walters has died at
the age of 93. she was famous for her
high profile interviews with world
leaders and celebrities alike and made
headlines in 1976 when she became the
first woman to present a flagship
evening news program her agent said she
died peacefully in her home surrounded
by loved ones
Health leaders have said that NHS a e
waiting times this winter are likely to
be the worst on records the Royal
College of emergency medicine has said
hospitals are struggling to cope with a
rise in demands brought on by covid flu
and strep a several NHS trusts have
already declared critical incidents
heavy rain wind and ice is expected to
lead to more flooding and travel
disruption in parts of the UK today a
yellow weather warning for rain was
issued for the south west of England and
much of Wales while a yellow warning for
ice remains in place in Northern
Scotland forecasters say the unsettled
weather is being caused by the deadly
winter storm That Sent temperatures
plunging in the U.S over Christmas
the New Year's Day celebrations have
begun across the world
Zealand has entered 2023 with their new
year at celebrations including the
fireworks and lights display in Auckland
large crowds gathered at the city Sky
Terror after covered restrictions forced
them to be canceled a year ago the
events included a laser light and
animation show which took in several
landmarks across the city
well Sydney always have a good display
we'll have that for you at 1pm this is
Sky News coming up we'll have more on
the breaking news that Pope Benedict the
16th has died at the age of 95.
as the year draws to an end
reflecting on the last 12 months a year
that saw the uniting of people through
adversity
after a long time separated While others
shouldn't have been this is it folks it
was a year of roaring together for the
lionesses and of quietness to pay our
respects of an end of an era to a start
of a new from disbelief to Hope
of people being at the heart of our
stories
as we collectively look back at the year
and look forward to the start of a new
we thank you for being there with us
from us to you
foreign
I'm Hannah Thomas Peter and I'm Sky's
climate change correspondent
the UK is a world leader in which
[Music]
people
it's part of the Congo based at
rainforest which is such an important
ecosystem it's known as the lungs of
Africa we aim to be the best and most
trusted place for news
she doesn't really enjoy speaking to the
press and it wasn't clear right up until
the last moment that she was going to
sit down with me I might be just very
naive but I do believe that change is
possible otherwise we wouldn't be
climate activists
[Music]
for the last 30 years we have known how
bad it is I'm not here to apologize I'm
here to fight for the next step
you can see just the piles and piles of
stuff these the sofas and people's desks
and children's books and you can see
inside this home here people trying to
uh to sort out their home it's just been
devastating
I think everything's at stake the future
of our planet the future of this beauty
around us
the future of you and me
thank you
let's return to our top story the death
of Pope Benedict XVI in 2013 benzix
became the first pontiff to resign in
600 years saying he no longer had the
physical and mental strength to run the
church
he discussed this as Foreign Affairs
author Tim Marshall who's in West London
and Tim we've been talking a lot about
the fact that uh Pope Benedict will be
remembered largely for for this this
decision really just to stand down
um as Paul well there is another Pope
taking who took his place what would you
say his legacy will be
I I come at it from the angle of Foreign
Affairs obviously and and the diplomacy
at the Vatican is uh quite a thing to
behold they have uh the oldest
Diplomatic Corps in the world uh it's
huge and they stretch all over the world
they have diplomatic relations with 180
countries and I think one of his
legacies is in that field of diplomacy
because he added during his what was it
five or six year reign he uh got
diplomatic relations with the UAE with
Malaysia with Montenegro
uh South Sudan I think Sudan as as well
that's quite a a coup especially with
Russia and I think that his relationship
with Putin helped bring together
uh the Russian Orthodox church and the
Roman Catholic church because well we
wouldn't have time to go into it too
much but since 1054 there was the great
schism
uh in in the church there are elements
in the Orthodox Church that believe they
are the new Rome they've always had
issues Russian Catholics were even more
persecuted during the Soviet years than
Orthodox Christians and so he met Putin
in the Vatican 2007 just a year after
thinking he became Pope and that really
did help relationships between the two
churches so I think it's uh that that's
that's a big plus there were negatives
it's interesting you bring up the
diplomacy there and the fact that he was
you know he had that relationship with
Vladimir Putin and given everything
we're seeing in the world today I mean
how enduring would you say that that
that diplomacy that has beaten well it
does help you know about the whole thing
about Georgia instead of war war I mean
the two churches have had some serious
issues between them and there were there
are and there were tensions between
um some Catholics and some Orthodox in
Russia and you know when you get a pope
meeting a president and then both saying
you know we need to get on better it
helps it helps to reduce those tensions
as I said there were some negatives
though
2006 he he made this speech and it was
perhaps slightly misconstrued but he
quoted a former Emperor who had pretty
much said that Islam spread through
violence now you can make an argument
for or against that but if the Pope says
it it causes a firestorm it did
and elements within the Islamic World
got very cross he ended up saying sorry
but he then went on to the Blue Mosque
in Istanbul only the second pope ever to
enter a mosque and again to try to to
bring faiths together Saudi king visited
uh the Vatican and again these are our
plus points the real negative though is
China
and I think this can be laid uh the door
of the new pope as well
the Chinese government will not
recognize the Vatican they do not have
diplomatic relations and the Chinese
government choose the Catholic Bishops
in China Rome doesn't choose them and
they've kind of
almost he or almost accepted that and
and Catholics that pay allegiance to
Rome in China are very much persecuted
that they have to worship underground
and I think he has he did he had he
tried to improve the lives of of
Catholics in China but but failed now is
that his fault or is it the fault of the
Chinese government uh but it it was not
excuse me it was not one of the
successes I think the success is trying
to bring the Orthodox and the Catholics
together and adding at least six or
seven countries to have diplomatic
relations uh with with with the Catholic
with the Vatican now and some people say
well how important is a pope and I think
that it is limited but and I'm reminded
of the old quote by Stalin when when the
pope of Stalin's time had criticized uh
the Kremlin and he said well how many
Legions has the pope got which is to say
non or
several billion if you look at the
Catholic Church
and I think we will see the influence
and the power that the Vatican has at
the funeral I think it's next Thursday
when you will see a steady stream of
world leaders showing up in Rome yes
Thursday January the 5th
um as we were reporting this morning Tim
Marshall fascinating to get that
analysis from you thank you very much
indeed
I've got time now for a quick check on
the weather
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well it will be unsettled this weekend
so the drier and less windy tomorrow but
Monday looks mostly fine so Southern
Britain will be very mild but windy
today with Coastal gills while the far
north will be called most other places
we'll see temperatures around average
for this time of year England and Wales
will be mostly cloudy without breaks of
rain this afternoon although Northern
England's mainly dry with brighter
spells likely south of Ireland will see
cloud and Rain else later on and
elsewhere Northern Ireland's the north
of Ireland and Central and Southern
Scotland's will be mostly dry with sunny
spells but northern Scotland's they'll
expect one tree shows
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
this is going east coming up three prime
ministers two heads of States there's a
year for British politics we'll look at
what 2023 might have in store
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is Sky News the top stories this
are former Pope Benedict's the 16th has
died at the age of 95.
the Vatican says Pope Benedict will lie
in state before his funeral only 5th of
January
and some of the lionesses are among
those celebrated in the King's first New
Year honors list
I want to update you on the situation in
Ukraine a short time ago we told you
about Air Raid Sirens sounding across
the country this lunch time with people
asked to take shelter the mayor of Kiev
Vitale Klitschko has issued a message on
social media saying there are explosions
in Kiev stay in shelters
one of the explosions rang out between
residential buildings in the solomayan
district of the capital all services
follow in place
explosions also took place in the
pasharsk district and hola Civic
districts there are there is destruction
rather Rescuers and Medics follow to the
places
Let's cross now to a correspondent usura
albertier she joins us now live from
Kiev now at yusra did you hear those Air
Raid Sirens can you just give us a sense
of what's happening there right now
yeah I mean we heard that I read sirens
in around 30 to 40 minutes later we
heard the blast there have been 10
blasts confirmed in Kiev so far and just
as we came out we saw plumes of smoke
Rising above the buildings here in the
capital well this is we're getting
reports that this is widespread south
and west of the country and even two
Russian drone attacks in in the west and
this is just two days after a Mass
Attack 69 Rockets fired into Ukraine
from Moscow and this is New Year's Eve
New Year's is the most celebrated
holiday here in Ukraine and Moscow is
sending a very very strong message
is there any indication Israel of the
the damage that's been sustained at this
time
I mean we we're still figuring out how
much damage has been been caused but
that confirmation from the mayor that a
missile that a blast was in a
residential area is very concerning
people are have been told to take
shelter and and the attack two days ago
which where the missiles were
intercepted coming into Kiev 16 of the
missiles were said to be intercepted
still saw three people wounded and and
two homes destroyed here so we're yet to
see what what will happen
okay Israel al-bagira giving us the
latest from Kiev in Ukraine used for
thanking
Richie sunac has warned the UK's
problems won't go away in 2023 as he
shared his new year's message after what
has been a challenging year for so many
the Prime Minister admitted there were
challenges still to come but said the
best of Britain would be on display over
the coming months the labor leaders
kirst armor used his message to call for
change
I'm not going to pretend that all our
problems will go away in the new year
for 2023 will give us an opportunity to
showcase the very best of Britain on the
world stage
continuing to stand with our Ukrainian
friends against Putin's brutality and
defending freedom and democracy wherever
we find it under threat
in this historic year of his majesty the
king's coronation we will come together
with pride in everything that makes this
country great
it's been another very tough year and
looking further afield a year when War
returned to our continent
this new year we must once again stand
by the people of Ukraine who've shown
such bravery fighting for their Liberty
and we must renew our vow to change our
country for the better
2023 is a new chapter for Britain with a
new king to be crowned in may we must
look forward to that with hope
foreign
Rob Powell joins us now from Westminster
and rob a recognition there from both
leaders that 2022 has been a year they'd
quite be happy to see the back of really
yeah I thought both messages were pretty
downbeat I think taken as a whole though
when you look at the texts of both of
them was maybe a touch more um
optimistic that's potentially not really
surprising given the political state of
both the parties um at the moment labor
consistently leading the conservatives
um in the polls but I think it's also
down to the sort of political messaging
that both men want to send out to the
public right now taking Wishy soon ACT
first he knows that all of the issues
the problems the challenges people are
facing at the moment with the economy
with inflation with Energy prices they
aren't going to go away in the immediate
future and in the months the immediate
months ahead they're probably going to
get worse and the whole point of Rishi
sunak if you like his whole res on Detra
and reason for being in number 10 is to
be honest with the public about those
challenges to try and fix as many of
them as he can and crucially to not sell
false hope that's why his message is
made maybe a little bit more downbeat
when he talks about not pretending all
of our problems will go away in the new
year I think though as we get deeper
into the year that political strategy if
you like of being honest to the point of
kind of abject bleakness that will get
less sustainable because as MPS see that
German election closing in they will
want something a little bit more
optimistic something to that they can
see that they can sell on the doorsteps
and I think they'll also want an
indication of what Rishi sunak stands
for as a politician Beyond just being a
bit of a political firefighter there to
fix problems as for Kier Stamos akirma I
think the reason why he was potentially
sounding a little bit more hopeful in
terms of laying out plans for the months
ahead is that this was probably the 12
months where a good chunk of people
within the labor party started genuinely
believing that they were going to win
the next election that kind of
breeziness and optimism was palpable at
the labor conference back in Autumn but
what many labor MPS and officials ignore
knowledge maybe more in private than in
public is that the party's got quite a
lot of work to do to actually set out
what it stands for and what it would do
in power because at the moment a lot of
the triumphs that the labor party is uh
are getting in the polls are mainly down
to the turmoil that's been created
mainly by the conservative party over
the last 12 months so they're sort of
trading off the conservatives misery and
if they're genuinely going to be on the
edge of taking power they need to do
more than just sort of heckle from the
sidelines they need to actually set out
some ideas some policies and tell a
story about what they would do if they
made it into government
okay we'll power their life Frozen
Westminster Rob thank you
no 2022 might have been a year of
tumults in Westminster but as we've just
heard political leaders are looking
ahead to the challenges of the next 12
months our political correspondents Joe
Pike has his predictions for 2023
Rishi sunak has been in his job for just
over two months kistama has been leading
labor for almost three years but both
will face big challenges in 2023
the war in Ukraine is likely to remain
the major foreign policy issue
whilst at home concerns over the economy
Energy prices and Industrial action will
dominate we are actually going to see
the cost of living crisis really biting
big questions will be asked of the
government what more support will you
continue to give not just households but
businesses who are struggling as well
and even though people are saying look
inflation will slowly come down over
time people aren't going to feel that
for some time the Prime Minister will be
judged on all that plus his new targets
to tackle illegal immigration and clear
the current backlog MP's on the right of
the party being really agitated with us
for some time I think MP's in the center
and even on the left realize that their
constituents really see this as a
problem so there is a general sense that
the government has to get a grip as much
as he wants to look to the Future Richie
sunac may be dragged back to
controversies of the past Boris Johnson
facing the Privileges committee big
questions been asked over the pandemic
handling we know that Dominic Rabb is
coming under lots of scrutiny and there
are increasing numbers of allegations
about bullying so even though Richie
sunak very much wants to be this sort of
Clean Skin and this fresh face for the
conservative party the recent history of
the conservative party is going to visit
him the sort of ghosts of Christmas Past
Richardson also needs to prove he's more
than just a technocrat and start to set
out his vision for the country at the
same time kistama's claim that he's
leading a government in Waiting or mean
he will face scrutiny like never before
you have polls consistently suggesting
that labor are going to win win a
majority and not just a small majority a
huge majority look at some of these
polls and that means they are going to
be under pressure to say more so far
labor I think are doing a pretty good
job to be quite evasive on things like
strikes on various issues even on
spending and I think that's going to be
harder particularly as the scrutiny
arrives and you see it on lots of his
interviews all almost being interviewed
as a government and waiting as opposed
to opposition Nicholas sturgeon will
hold a special SMP conference to work
out the next steps in the fight for
Scottish independence wrangling over the
Northern Ireland protocol could lead to
another storm and election Ed Davey will
be hoping he can rebuild support for the
liberal Democrats whilst Nigel farage's
Reform Party could prove a threat to the
conservatives
2023 is likely to be the last full year
before a general election so the
impending battle for number 10 will be
on every politician's mind
police in the United States have
arrested a man over the murders of four
students in a house near their
University in Idaho the 28 year old was
detained in eastern Pennsylvania more
than 2 000 miles from where the killings
took place a U.S correspondents Martha
Kellner reports
it's the Breakthrough their families
have been desperate for a man arrested
in connection with the brutal murder of
four University students a crime which
has tormented a town and mystified
America
housemates Kaylee gonsalves Madison
Mogan and zanica nodal and sana's
boyfriend Ethan Chapin was stabbed to
death in their beds in this student home
in the small town of Moscow Idaho
after six weeks and with fears that this
case was going cold their suspected
killer was tracked down 2500 miles away
in Pennsylvania
28 year old Brian coburger was a
criminology student at a nearby
University
Brian coburger
shows him graduating from another
University earlier this year
what I can tell you is we have an
individual in custody who committed
these horrible crimes and I do believe
our community is safe
one of the many unknowns pervading this
case is why the three-story house or its
occupants were targeted and why some
were left alive
on the first floor Zana and her
boyfriend Ethan who were sharing a bed
were killed
on the second floor Kaylee and lifelong
best friend Maddie also sharing a bed
were murdered two other female
housemates in ground floor bedrooms say
they slept through the attacks when they
woke they summoned other friends to the
house believing one housemate to be
unconscious police have ruled them out
as Suspects
police say they're still trying to build
the case against Cole Burger appealing
for the public to continue coming to
them with information this is not the
end of this investigation in fact this
is a new beginning
you all now know the name of the person
who's been charged with these offenses
please get that information out there
please ask the public anyone who knows
about this individual to come forward
call the tip line
furniture and all the belongings were
removed from the crime scene today under
a top holding cover the process was
suddenly halted police say at the
request of the Court
but after six weeks with little sign of
any progress being made in this murder
inquiry Moscow police now believe they
have their man Martha Kellner Sky News
this is Sky News coming up we'll have
more reaction to the release of the new
year honors list the actress and
Wildlife campaigner has been made a day
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Stuart Ramsey and I'm Sky's Chief
correspondent
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
[Music]
welcome back the King has released his
first New Year's honors list and as you
would expect there's a mix of awards for
people famous or not who have achieved
remarkable things among them is Virginia
McKenna the actress and co-founder of
the Born Free Foundation which campaigns
for animals to release to
remain free from captivity rather well
she's become a Dame after decades
committed to the work of her world life
charity and I'm very pleased to say that
lady Virginia and her son the executive
president of the Born Free Foundation
World Travers join me now many
congratulations uh to you lady Virginia
on this honor that you've received
very much I find it quite hard to know
what to say to be honest with you
because it's
such an unexpected and such a great
honor to have been recognized
for our work because I didn't do it all
by myself I can assure you it will my
late husband Bill we did it we started
it the three of us together
um it's it's a great honor but I mean
arguably you've managed to all three of
you have managed to achieve great great
things just looking through the the
achievements the Born Free Foundation
has managed to uh has managed to come up
with it you've supported government
legislation you've contributed to the
Animal Welfare act and you're still
going now I mean what are you most proud
of that you've achieved through the Born
Free Foundation
I suppose the main thing is that well
two things really first of all that
we've encouraged people to look on
other people
as individuals and animals as
individuals no animals the same as the
next one like us we're not the same as
The Neighbor Next Door
and that that applies to animals too we
ought to look at respect them honor them
love them care for them not to be cruel
to them as individuals some will be more
resilient than others others won't and
we have to recognize the individuality
and the sensitivity
of animals which we often admire for
their loving care of their young
and the way they they live with other
creatures and in harmony you know
sometimes we don't do that but they do
and we Revere the elephant and yet we
put elephants in captivity and give them
sometimes not always but sometimes a
concrete compound and that's where they
spend the rest of their lives and that
to me is
is not being kind to other creatures and
teaching the wrong lesson to people who
come and look at them absolutely well I
mean it's we are a nation of animal
lovers here in the UK it's very rare to
see an elephant and a concrete enclosure
here in this country and certainly the
legislation that has been passed thanks
to the the work of the Born Free
Foundation
really has helped go some way towards uh
towards making conditions a lot better
for Animals here in the United Kingdom
would you say it's job done
oh no never
the job is never done and you said go
some way
some way yes but not enough not enough
way and I think
we need to think much more deeply about
this issue
um especially for sentient beings like
elephants like all creatures frankly
we're not the only creature or living
being that has feelings and emotions
animals do as well they have anger they
have Pride they have suffering they have
joy as we do and we should respect that
and not think we are the master race as
it were I don't know whether my son
wants to add any more to that more
eloquently than me
well um hello I think that that um
you're very kind to say that we've made
some progress it's not just being us of
course there's been many many other
groups it's so wonderful to see that
Brian May has also received a Knighthood
in the honors not just for his amazing
music but for his campaigning work for
animals so we we don't have wild animals
in circuses anymore we don't have any
dolphins in Dolphin area in the UK we're
beginning to look closely at the keeping
of exotic animals as pets and whether
that's appropriate and keeping a wild
animal as a pet is seems to be
inappropriate in in the United States
we've supported the recent passing of
the big cat and public safety act which
kind of fed off of what was shown in
Tiger King the keeping of large
dangerous wild animals for commercial
exploitation by private individuals that
will that will come to an end as well
fighting the ivory trade the government
here has been on the front foot as far
as that is concerned but there is my mum
is right there is so much more to do and
just quickly
um what lies ahead for the Born Free
foundation and the activism that you
both are suppose what are the next steps
for you
oh my goodness well
probably following many of the same
paths just being stronger on those paths
with what we feel justice has to be done
for innocent wild creatures
um I'm not quite sure will would
probably well inspiring you're
particularly Keen to inspire the younger
generation the voice that we've just
actually brought a 19 year old here I am
with a 91 year old we've just brought a
19 year old onto our board so that the
voice of young people can be heard at
the top table where it's uh it's
absolutely essential and of course we're
looking
we're looking Beyond trophy hunting for
example we're looking for a different
future that protects Wildlife protects
habitats and helps rural people achieve
their potential without the killing of
wild animals for fun
okay so the work very much continues uh
will Travis from the Bourne free
foundation and Lady of Virginia great to
have you with us here on Sky News and
many congratulations again for uh your
honor there at least in the New Year's
honors thank you for asking us to come
on your program thank you
I've just got time for a quick check on
the weather now
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well there'll be an unsettled weekend
but drier and less windy tomorrow and
Monday looks mostly fine Southern
Britain will be very mild but windy
today Coastal Gales or in the far north
it is looking very cold most other
places set sea temperatures around
average for this time of year
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
this is Sky News coming up we'll take
you live to Sydney where they're just
about to bring in the New Year
we're sure to be a spectacular display
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Australia where New Year's Eve
celebrations are about to begin a quick
warning there will be some flashing
images soon
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
well there we have it Sydney Australia
welcoming in 2023 in style with that
spectacular fireworks display along the
Sydney Waterfront they join New Zealand
of course in
2023 here in London however we're still
very much firmly in 2022
our fireworks will come a little bit
later on in the day
well let's take you now to the top story
of course tributes are being paid to
former Pope Benedict XVI who died this
morning age 95. in 2013 Pope Benedict
became the first pontiff to resign in
600 years saying he no longer had the
physical and mental strength to run the
church the head of the Catholic church
in England Cardinal Vincent Nichols has
said Pope Benedict was one of the great
theologians of the 20th century we'll
have more on the tribute side this
morning by the prime minister in a
moment first though our Europe
correspondent Sean Robbins looks back at
Benedict xvi's Life and Legacy
foreign
as the intellectual Pope the son of a
policeman a child who lived through Nazi
rule in 2005 Cardinal Joseph ratzinger
became Benedict XVI the first German to
be elected Pope in a thousand years
an uncompromising theological
conservative Cardinals chose him as a
safe Pair of Hands
Benedict Was a shy person he loved books
he loved his desk writing reflecting
bringing in beautiful German and then
also in other languages his thought but
a lonely person
he was even telling people my true
friends are the books
nickname God's rottweiler for his
uncompromising conservative views is a
cardinal I at times his eight-year
papacy was marked by missteps the
rehabilitation of a holocaust denier
angering Jews a clumsy speech
antagonizing Muslims
but many respected his deep faith
his strength was clearly how to express
the Christian faith in a way
understandable to Modern human beings
that's
his message that's what he leaves us
among Catholics Benedict Was widely
popular in 2010 he made the first ever
papal State visit to the UK welcomed by
a crowd of adoring pilgrims
before meeting Queen Elizabeth
politicians and giving dozens of sermons
but his visit was controversial for
critics who claimed he was not doing
enough to tackle sex abuse in the church
a topic which would haunt him into his
retirement
the number one challenge for Pope
Benedict Was the abuse crisis which was
just gaining it in in speed and
spreading all over the world during his
pontificate and he did take several
steps to begin to respond to that but
his critics say that he he didn't do
enough in the time that he was the pope
in 2013 tired by a Vatican League
Scandal and dogged by ill health
benedict made history again
this time becoming the first pope in 600
years to resign
in his final address to the faithful
he acknowledged the weight of the office
and the church's problems
it was a journey with joy and light but
there have also been difficult moments
[Applause]
than in an extraordinary chapter for the
Catholic church he said goodbye to the
Cardinals before retiring to a monastery
in Vatican City
that was a remarkable step he made and
there hadn't been a pop since the Middle
Ages though who stepped down so he as a
fairly conservative person was also
opening a door
to a world of today where people need
not to stay in office until they die
after retirement Benedict chose to keep
wearing white give interviews and not
revert to his old name decisions critics
claimed threatened the unity in the
church
but the two popes personal relationship
was strong France is referring to his
predecessor as a grandfather figure and
asking people to pray for his friend as
his health deteriorated
he's very sick he told worshipers in
December asking the Lord to comfort him
to the very end
today Benedict is remembered again as
millions of Catholics around the world
pray for the man who led their church
for almost a decade Robbins